good morning to all members of our
committee and good morning to our public
uh welcome to house education
uh we are prepared now to move forward
with today's hearings on our bills the
first bill on the docket for today is hb
1164.
uh unfortunately the prime sponsor and
the only sponsor is uh
upstairs and he's going to try to get
down here to us so what we'll do on the
interim we're going to have is we've
done here in education many times before
we'll have it introduced by a member of
the committee
and then we'll keep it open and if
representative pearl is able to get here
this bill is revising the agriculture
and the classroom committee
so with that i'd welcome
representative cordelli who is standing
in and willing to just uh
present that bill to us
uh thank you mr chairman
for the record uh representative glenn
cordelli representing tuftenborough
moultonborough on sandwich in the
beautiful lakes region and i would like
to introduce house bill
which is an amendment
to the statute for the existing
thank you very much for introducing the
bill and
is there anybody from the public would
like to speak on that bill at this
particular time i don't have any pink
cards here
so i'm just going to keep this open in
case representative pearl can break
loose from his meetings i believe
upstairs
and he could get here so um just hang
loose at this time please and
we have until 9 30 when the next bill
starts
for for members of the committee we are
streaming so make sure your your your
mics are off
can you just give us about 30 seconds or
right there and whatever
okay for members of our committee we uh
as i spoke earlier that the chair was
coming downstairs to speak on this bill
uh the bill is 1164. it has been
introduced representative pearl
uh however if you care to like to speak
on the bill you're more than welcome to
welcome to our committee
uh representative pearl
thank you very much and my apologies i
had this on my schedule it's next
tuesday
for the record my uh my name is
representative howard pearl from loudoun
and i represent uh merrimack 26.
i introduced uh house bill 116 i
submitted house bill 1164 on at the
request of the department of agriculture
commissioner commissioner jasper he had
some concerns with the
language as it was written and he wanted
to make some changes
so he provided this language for me and
with his assistance in the ag's office
this is the language that we had i was
hopeful he was going to be here to
really describe it because i'm not
necessarily prepared to do that but i
wanted to introduce and offer it to him
to describe
so i
do not know i don't see any members from
the department here
i won't do a good job describing it
honestly because i was really prepared
for him to do it so
but i can tell you that
there's no substantial changes but it
does fix some areas where there were
basically two different um sections in
in large that it was
we had like competing um
committees that were occurring and they
really needed to be appointed by the
governor so
rather than the way they had been
previously appointed so this kind of
cleans that up and and gets the language
to where it needs to be to work properly
i do know that i've spoken with some
members of the
committee currently and they are in
agreement with the language of the ag in
the classroom committee so
with that i don't have a lot more to add
in my apologies again for being late i
really don't know why i had this on next
tuesday and i must have entered it
improperly in my calendar
maybe not uncommon but a little
embarrassing so my apologies well that's
fine are there any questions from
committee members here represent
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
representative pearl
um
it
it seems as though there are no
legislators in the current statute or in
this
revised
classroom committee agriculture in the
classroom committee
i'm just wondering do you think that
there should be
some representatives of the legislature
on the committee
thank you for the question so i guess i
would say representative that uh
again this this language was drafted by
the commissioner himself and with the
approval of the ag and with the approval
of the current ag in the classroom
committee and
i guess since we've not had any there
and we really aren't having any issues
this you know that i don't know that it
would be necessary but certainly if your
committee wishes to add some i guess my
recommendation would be to have that
conversation with commissioner jasper
and make sure that he would be okay with
it thank you you're welcome further
yeah since you're not
um jasper i'm not sure you can actually
answer this but i'll ask in case you can
i just wondered what happened to the new
hampshire fruit growers association and
the new hampshire farmers market
association because they were in the
other one and they're not in this one
sure again thank you for the question uh
that was some of the things that needed
to be cleaned up because by statute my
understanding is these positions needed
to be appointed by the governor and it
was we sort of had a secondary board
that was just a collection of people
that were were there and doing the job
and not that it was going badly but the
commissioner is trying to clean it up
and get it so that it complies with the
statute
thank you you're welcome representative
hobson do you have a question yes i just
have a brief question thank you mr chair
and thank you pearl for taking my
question did you say that this was an
existing committee already
okay yes thank you thank you yes there
was a committee and again there was
it was just some conflict in the way
that it had been done and the
commissioner is trying to get it so that
it is established
correctly according to the statute
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative i'm over here behind the
speaker i'm sorry i know it's okay i
can't see you either
uh at roman two line eight the committee
shall be a not-for-profit voluntary
corporation
and shall possess all general powers of
uh why um
why was there a change having it moved
from just a
run-of-the-mill committee if you will to
a non-for pro not-for-profit corporation
thank you that's a great question i'm
going to really ask you to direct that
more to the commissioner when you have
an opportunity to speak with him but my
understanding is that they received some
funding and they wanted to make sure
that they were following having the
proper protocols in place so that they
as a not-for-profit they would have that
where they wouldn't have the oversight
previously that was my understanding but
i would again defer to the commissioner
really to answer that question properly
thank you thank you representative do
representative tanner thank you
um i was wondering why this bill came to
education and not agriculture
i that is a great question and i guess
that was the purview of this the speaker
made that choice and i did not have a
discussion with him so i'd have to defer
that question to him is that why that
choice was made
thank you yeah we could have vacated it
to you you could have um
so i i i want to just follow up on the
track that representative cordelli was
on i've worked with the farm bureau you
have a bill that's coming up that's ours
on
next week dealing with the uh
fairs in the state and capital support
to them um
so and i and and putting that together
i've worked very closely with the farm
bureau and the fair associations etc
that are dealing with agriculture
and and and marketing of uh farm produce
um so
so do you would you support i i i heard
you speak about to represent courtney
but would you support our putting a
a legislator on there so that this is
the first time i've ever heard of this
committee uh
and other than seeing it in the bill
so that we can have some input and
communicate what's going on with the
legislature i know the farm bureau is
very interested and i they work with you
but on this particular aspect of
education well thank you for the
question i would not oppose it as long
as it wasn't me
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding i i got you
no i would not oppose it i think if that
is the will of the committee again i
would encourage that a conversation is
had with the commissioner so that he's
um up to speed and
you know and and he may have some
objections that i'm not aware of but
personally i would not have any
objection to thank you and represent you
got a hand up again i do thank you i
should have followed up
my first time around mr chair uh
representative uh
further down in roman numeral two
one of those duties and powers is to
hire and and
oversee an education director for the
program
um my question is twofold one is there
currently a director and two in the
absence of a director because i see that
it
is finance dependent and i don't see a
financial note on the bill
so i'm just wondering in the absence of
hiring a director who would in fact be
administering this sure thank you for
the question i can tell you the first
part i can answer with
certainty yes there is a director now
it's a part-time position if i remember
correctly i've worked some with with deb
on this um
i guess in the absence of funding i'm
not sure exactly how it would go it
hasn't been a problem because there has
been there's there's a couple of
different funding sources and again i
really wish the commissioner was here to
speak to it he's much more knowledgeable
on this topic than i am but i do know
there's donations made from new
hampshire farm bureau and i believe
there's there's another source as well
but again i don't want to speak to
something that i'm not certain of but i
do know there's a secondary source that
seems to provide steady enough funding
to keep a director in place
thank you representative
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much representative pearl for uh
for bringing this
forward um why wouldn't um
a committee like this or um
or an organization like this
just uh organized like so many of the
non-profits uh here in the concord area
that advocate on behalf of so many
different um
uh causes not just here in the education
committee but um but you know in in in
all
other elements of
of um state policy and uh you know
organized as a non-profit worked with
new hampshire charitable foundation
among among others um you know for
funding
and um and not be
hamstrung
to um you know specific uh statute
sure that's a great question in this
the ag in the crafts classroom program
has been existent for quite a number of
years and again it had provisions within
statute that it established it and i
guess i don't know going back to the
roots why it was started that way
but that's the way it has been and this
just kind of cleaned up some concerns
that the the commissioner had with the
way that uh things had been operating he
was trying to make it to comply more
with the will of the legislature in the
in the current statute
so again i i would encourage perhaps you
could have the commissioner come in for
another time
and and speak more in depth and i
apologize i i don't like not giving you
complete and in full answers but i'm
certainly sharing you to the best of the
knowledge that i have
thank you
representative woodcock thank you
everyone away it was a real good morning
thank you good morning i was following
trying to find the bill and the
education
uh
laws for research which i couldn't
obviously they weren't there um but they
are on this little magnificent computer
and it was 2009 when it first started
but i'm looking at the bill as presented
here
and i'm thinking about what what is
someone may say uh one of our leaders
what is the intent of this i'm looking
at line five and six
uh where it says that the k-12 students
throughout the state using
interdisciplinary education i understand
by reading the old bill 2009 where the
committee people the different
organizations are restructuring the
affiliate i get that
and everyone else is pretty much the
same but where where is this going
where is this statewide k-12
interdisciplinary education going
because that's not in the original 2009
bill as i read it
well thank you for the question though
i'm not quite sure i'm clear on what
you're looking for where is it going
mean what is the future of the program
when it says throughout k-12 throughout
the state is this going to be a new
program
uh put in because it's not listed as
such in the old bills let's say creating
curriculum and stuff but um where is
this going with was now is in the
mission to do that sure okay i think i
have a little bit of thank you my
understanding is this to continue the
same program that's been going on
ongoing for many years and i'm not aware
that there's any move to make any
changes from what it's currently been
doing
it provides a lot of good education and
a little bit of
funding and expertise to sometimes to
school teachers to do you know might be
a maple syrup program or it might be a
you know a seed growing program or
something like that to sort of introduce
the kids to agriculture and
allow them to
kind of have fun with it and see the
benefits of it within their own life you
know we might inspire them to go home
and have their family grow a garden or
something along that line so that's the
current program and my understanding is
that's what it's intended to state
thank you follow up thank you so you
don't see this right you'll see this as
the intent to create more legislation
and add into the curriculum k to 12. i
do not okay thank you very much
president pearl thank you represent like
us
i'm just curious
seeing this which i didn't know existed
i think it's cool
um do you know if any schools do field
trips to particular agricultural things
i remember when i was a kid
every year in elementary school we went
to the local dairy
and saw how it worked i'm you know and
that made me think of that and i just
wondered if you knew if that happens now
sure thank you for the question
i'm not certain that they do necessarily
related to this program
i certainly know the schools have come
to my own farm for maple tours and
things of that nature and back when i
dairy farm they did as well again i
don't know that it was associated
specifically to the ag in the classroom
program
to my knowledge they don't set up tours
themselves but they certainly do work
with the producers excuse me the
teachers to
help them and aid them in some expertise
and things that they need to do the
various programs that are offered again
i'm most familiar with the maple syrup
program because of my own
participation within that industry but
it's a great program and i've judged the
competition on many occasions and it's
really fun to see the excitement from
the school kids as they produce a quart
of maple syrup and they and for those
who don't know it's it's basically a
small competition where the students
have to work you know they work with
their teachers and they there's a few
certain rules they have to follow they
set taps they do the whole production
and in some cases they get a little
bigger than that they'll even get into
some of the more innovative equipment
like osmosis units and things of that
nature but there's some a little bit of
funding that comes from some of us that
are involved in the industry that will
help provide you know
at cost equipment and things like that
and donations are made at times and
in the end there's a little competition
where they put their court of syrup in
and
it's similar to what you'll see at the
fair and i i've um
i've helped to judge that competition
there's a few criteria they have to meet
it's really fun to for them to
understand and learn uh you know the
chemistry that is involved in production
of syrup as well as just how they
interact with the trees in the nature
and in the end they get something really
well thank you very much yes represent
thank you
i apologize for being late and perhaps
this was raised before i got here but
i'm looking at this as a non-profit
corporation where we've got the
legislature appointing the membership
and the leadership on it and then and
and from a legal point that that just
makes me uncomfortable i'm not sure that
the we're not conflicting with the laws
on creating nonprofit corporations and
i'm wondering if you're aware of any
other non-profit that is directed the
same way by the legislature as this is
where basically all the membership and
the leadership and the terms are defined
by the rsa but it's also a corporation
it's just an unusual combination sure
thank you for the question um
again this bill
was
given to me by commissioner jasper he
was looking at the current language that
they had and he was fixing some
conflicts that he saw and he did consult
with the attorney general's office and
they had a hand in writing this so i'm
reasonably comfortable in saying that
there shouldn't be any conflicts as much
as i i could be it has been vetted
through the proper channels to make sure
that that doesn't exist
thank you
it is an unusual setup so but thank you
certainly you're welcome
okay not seeing any more hands and i
know you have to run upstairs we
appreciate you getting down to us again
i apologize my apologies for being late
and i hope you have a good rest of your
day thank you thank you very much you
from others in the public so i'm going
to close this hearing
okay in about two minutes we start off
um
uh
i can mention to all the folks here that
i know that
i'm looking at the list of membership on
that last committee and the various
associations
and i can say that
in in grafton county we still have a
farm at grafton county and that works
with the schools directly and brings
them in when we grow the pumpkins the
kids take pumpkins home going down uh
all those the cooperative extension
service out of grafton county works
directly with the schools and goes in
the maple syrup grows there's a museum
that's part of the fair and they also
get involved with making a maple syrup
the kids sell christmas trees and that
works with the christmas tree
uh
council there i i believe there's such a
yeah the christmas tree promotion board
and the dairy with hatchling dairy in
town they do the same thing so
agriculture in an agriculture community
really benefits from these individual
associations i don't know how they
combine into
one
community or one organization maybe that
helps coordinate it but uh
i'd like to pursue getting more
information we will get
commissioner sean jasper involved in
this and try and get some more
insight in terms of your questions
yes
uh mr chair uh i'm wondering too how
this coordinates with the unh extension
service um and and wondering if we can
get some information there as well
that'd be fine and and that's the
extension service i was talking about
out of grafton county that is unh
and so having a better understanding of
how that works as well so
um
yes yes that i i it's that right at the
well that's another area we want to look
at too uh
the whole concept of this or the whole
issue
is just like the issue we had the other
day where we were trying to find
something in statutes not in statutor in
our hard
books
and this one too is another one that's
the the first time i've ever dealt with
this committee i've dealt with the the
farm bureau i've dealt with all the
individual associations
closely in terms of
uh property taxes
assessing uh you know
buildings on farms and all that with
municipal and county government and et
cetera but never this topic and
it's interesting i'd like to know more
about it so we'll get this and we'll
continue working as uh
maybe a committee of the whole and and
and try to get more information before
okay with that we are
flowing into the next uh part of our
our a day's work
hb 1058 relative to the time allowed for
the
public school students to eat lunch
the prime sponsor of the bill is
with us
uh thank you mr chair and thank you to
the committee for having me back
um i think i'm a little bit more
prepared this time so i i hope that's
appreciated um so house bill 1058 and
act relative to the time allowed for
public school students to eat lunch so
first i'm going to explain exactly what
this bill does not do to kind of dispel
some
you know some maybe some
misunderstandings that i've heard from
either colleagues or possibly
constituents and maybe other
stakeholders too so this legislation
does not mandate the time length of
lunch periods theoretically schools
could keep their current lunch period
periods nearly unchanged and ensure
children receive 20 minutes to sit and
eat this could even happen in the
classroom if a child received their meal
towards the end of lunch the child could
just stay and also finish their meal
during the subsequent lunch block
this legislation does not require the
school day to become a lot longer if
more lunch periods are necessary the
school districts can have lunch periods
that overlap school districts around the
country do this this stuff so how would
it kind of work is the first group of
students would occupy only half the
lunchroom these students would get their
meals sit and eat then a new group of
students would get their meals and fill
up the lunchroom the original students
that got the first meal would finish
eating after 20 minutes and vacate the
lunchroom and then a new group of
students would begin receiving their
meals after the second group is served
and already sitting the cycle would
continue and saves everyone time it
means meals are served constantly and
children are continuously eating and
provided enough time it's done
especially in a lot of urban settings
where the infrastructure might become
stressed this legislation does not
change the amount of labor needed to
prepare meals the number of meals served
will not change unless a number of
students changes this legislation will
not force students to sit and eat for 20
minutes schools are only required to
provide
20 minutes for eating if a student is
done with lunch and does not want to
stay the student's lunch can be finished
teachers or parents do not oppose this
legislation the teachers unions have
been worked and consulted and to my
understanding support the legislation
because it would provide more
preparatory time during the middle of
the day and more substantial lunch break
for teachers and decreases children's
hunger in the classroom parents like
this legislation because they want their
children to eat not come home with half
full lunch boxes parents also want their
children to eat during lunch time and
not you know eating outside of um you
know very strange times in some school
districts in the state sometimes lunches
will even start at 10 10 o'clock 10 30
in the morning to me that sounds a lot
more like breakfast and less like lunch
i guess it depends on when you wake up
in the morning so what does this
legislation precisely do
house bill 1058 requires schools to give
students 20 minutes to sit and eat as i
mentioned in my testimony on house bill
1561 that you heard last week relative
to the school nutrition standards less
hungry and healthier students perform
better in the classroom leading federal
agencies in the cdc suggests that
children need 20 minutes to eat their
meals the average student in america is
only receiving 12 minutes to eat their
meals right now
allowing 20 minutes to eat leads to
better success later in life and
decreased costs for society according to
the food research and action center
quote children experiencing hunger are
more likely to be hyperactive absent and
tardy in addition to having behavioral
and attention problems more often
than other children and quote teens
experiencing hunger are more likely to
have been suspended from school and have
difficulty getting along with other
children end quote
children with hunger are more likely to
have repeated agreed receive special
education services or receive mental
health counseling than low-income
children who do not experience hunger
hunger results in lost class time for
students lower test scores lower
academic achievement and
it makes student making students less
hungry and fulfilling their nutritional
needs will hopefully help those who fall
through the cracks that we see from time
to time in our public education system
1058 does require lunch to be served
between the hours of 11am and 2pm why is
this necessary well because some school
districts will provide students with
lunch with breakfast sorry excuse me
with breakfast at around 8am and then
students back for lunch sometimes at
around 10 a.m i'm unsure if anyone
willingly eats on this schedule anywhere
else in our society
but schools force students to do this
every day in new hampshire eating lunch
and breakfast in such a short period of
time makes younger and older students
famish by the afternoon which will hurt
their concentration
students will then struggle to
concentrate in the class and this eating
schedule also messes up families
scheduling of nightly supper and hurts
young metabolisms right so if you have
students that come home at three o'clock
that would like another meal it might
mess up you know a planned meal for five
to six o'clock they may not eat their
entire meal that might be more
nutritious in an at-home snack so and
not to mention the metabolism part it's
not good for young metabolism to be fed
so much in the morning and then to wait
so long for another prepared meal later
on in the day from once they get home so
um one last point is a socialized the
socialization aspect of lunch is vital
to children too it is essential that
students sit eat and socialize with
their peers this helps children develop
and blow off steam as americans we have
sort of forgotten how important it is to
sit down together for our meals even at
an evening supper so uh i hope this
clarifies house bill 1058 i'll remain
open to any questions thank you very
much
are there any questions from the
committee on this representative
cordelli
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative
um
20 minutes of seated time
separate from the full lunch period
um
do you expect i don't know if you have
any children
but do you expect elementary school
children to remain seated
for 20 minutes
i would not expect children to sit for
20 minutes and the bill doesn't mandate
that children sit
i would i would find that mandate to be
impossible to uh to enforce um it just
requires schools to provide 20 minutes
and who would keep track of the 20
minutes would be
presumably the faculty and the
administrators in the room who are
already making sure that children are
coming and going from the lunchroom
making sure that they're eating at the
proper time period that the school's
already allotting for and that they're
going to and from the classroom properly
and respectfully
to my understanding that's what uh when
having conversations with the school
administrators association the school
board association that's how they viewed
the enforcement would happen
follow-up
yes thank you
um on line 11
you specify the times for lunch periods
but exemptions may apply for shortened
days
so
for an exemption from that time period
i think it's kind of similar to how it
currently works in a lot of school
districts where for example if you have
a a delay in the school day you might
end up serving lunch maybe a little bit
later
you might go outside of that two o'clock
time frame
i would assume the exemption would come
from the department of education but i
could be mistaken that might be a better
question for the department
are there further questions of the
presenter representative woodcock and
then representative bowm
thank you for the trap all right
whenever the shades are doing
good to see you again i'm well thank you
representing woodcock um just a quick
question uh brodie in your dialogue
you're talking about um
youngsters 1984 11 because they start on
eight issues very small i get that so
some of the high schools have started
seven and seven fifteen
would this be able to be moved back or
you still want to stay leveraged frame
i i would be um i'd be more than amiable
to any kind of amendment to expanding
the 11 to 2 o'clock frame maybe to 10 30
to 2 30 to um
yeah to correspond with earlier schools
that may start earlier i think that's a
i think that's a good idea i still think
according to you know a number of
federal studies and studies done by
research institutions um nonpartisan
research institutions it still says that
students even if they are eating
breakfast maybe at seven the best time
to eat lunch is still between ten
o'clock and two o'clock but i understand
we have to be flexible so i i think
that's a more than
reasonable approach thank you thank you
mr chairman representative
thank you mr chairman thank you taking
the question
uh i know some school districts have a
problem with the number of students in
the school and the size of their
cafeteria they have a problem scheduling
so don't you think in some cases this
might need a financial note
to apply for the hour the number of
hours
you're only
allowing three hours for lunch
and in some cases it might take longer
uh thank you for your question
representative um
i don't think it would require a local
fiscal note because as i mentioned
there's a lot of ways for schools to
work their schedule to make it so then
there would be no cost and these are
it's not like reinventing the wheel
these are solutions that are used across
the country by school districts that are
both rural and urban um i don't think
that it would require any more labor
because the same amount of meals will be
served to the same amount of students as
we're being served before
so and also technically speaking you're
also shortening up the amount of time
that lunch is served so you might
actually end up seeing uh you know the
the number of hours for food workers um
sorry that that's not the best term to
use for people who are serving these
meals to students it might end up
shortening their day right because if
they're only serving lunch from 11 to
two rather than serving from 10 to 3
right that saves them more time to prep
in the beginning of the day more time to
prep at the end of the day and they
might have to they might not show up to
school as early anymore and they might
be able to leave from the school
follow up thank you
i'm thinking missed the question the
question is the size of the cafeteria
may result in needing more than three
hours even if if we go with the 20
minutes and 30 minutes so that would
require the school to
add on to the cafeteria
and that's my question why a financial
note might be needed
um well thank you for clarifying
representative my apologies for not
answering your your initial question i
thought i had understood it
i still i don't think it would
necessarily be needed to expand the
cafeterias if school districts work
their schedules properly with kind of
how i described overlapping lunch
periods for students
maybe i'm mistaken though but i think it
would be able to work without a fiscal
note but that might be something worth
asking um maybe the department of
education
further questions from the committee
representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question um this is another the ideas i
think are great but do you not think
maybe it's better to leave it up to
local control where they know
how long it takes their students to eat
what time their students are arriving at
school you know i know just for an
example i know the hooks students go to
pinkerton academy in derry
uh for high school
they're on the bus probably 45 minutes
to an hour i'm sure they're leaving
their houses by 6 30 in the morning you
know they they're probably very hungry
by 10 30
a.m so it's it's up
i think every school every district
knows
what their students want and i and as
someone who's done lunch duty i think
saying that students can't sit still for
20 minutes if you in fact let a whole
grade of students
get up out of their seats and start
wandering around the cafeteria it's
i you know socializing around their
table always happens and is great and
they get to choose who they eat with but
students getting up and socializing all
around the whole cafeteria
it doesn't work but but
it's a good idea thank you well thank
you for your uh your question
representative and um i i don't think
the bill would in any way require uh
schools to have children walk around the
cafeteria socializing
i think i think it would only require
them to be
to for schools to provide 20 minutes if
the student chooses to utilize that 20
minutes i also think i'm an important
thing that we have to remember in new
hampshire as well we like to preserve
local control as much as we can
new hampshire's still a dylan rural
state so it's pretty regular for the
state to set guard rails and guidelines
for kind of basic expectations for how
local governments treat their uh treat
our constituents right and how they
serve those constituents and you know
very regularly um committees you know
such as this one too will will create
and formulate legislation working with
stakeholders to establish those
guidelines of how public education and
and uh you know a number of other
educational choices how they'll look
throughout the state so um i can
understand why some people might be
concerned about losing some aspect of
local control but i think another every
other are provided 30 minutes to eat
when the average student in new
hampshire is only getting about 12
minutes to eat
i think it makes sense to uh to kind of
address that concern it's a concern
that's been raised to me in my time as
being a legislator from parents
it's a concern that's actually been
brought up a lot to the department of
education when speaking with them they
said it was actually a very large
complaint that they received it tend to
be
a number of coveted restrictions or lack
thereof and then this was typically the
next biggest issue that was on parents
minds and um
you know you are right it does vary
depending on the on the school district
but i still think you know there's ways
for the committee to formulate this
legislation to continue working with the
stakeholders because i've done a lot
working with them on speaking with them
and having a dialogue with them to um to
make it so this legislation could be um
could be easy for school districts to
implement and to handle okay we need to
go on another question because we're
running out of time representative
apologies
thank you mr chair and thank you for
filing this bill having been a teacher
in elementary school with a 12-minute
lunch
honest on a day when i have recess duty
was definitely a stressor and i think i
appreciate your efforts i'm concerned
did you when you were talking with um
stakeholders about this what did they
talk about with recess especially in the
lower grades usually the way it works
the kids
got if you get them to wash your hands
their hands before you they go to lunch
then it could be a half an hour before
lunch and then they go in and have their
lunch and then they go out and play
how would that work with this how would
that have you did you
run into any concerns with recess
if this bill were to pass or among the
stakeholders and that like
the teachers unions and the
associated
i'll be brief in the interest of time um
uh no no one brought up any concern
about this conflicting or um in any way
kind of creating a scheduling conflict
with recess thank you
further questions
yes representative nelson thank you for
taking my question
early release what happens on that day
the school has to close because of a
snowstorm and my second one is i see
here in the rochester middle school here
in new hampshire they sometimes have a
so i think i think the uh for example
when we have the exemptions may apply
for certain school days i think that
would be a prime example of when an
exemption would be needed on that
saturday day um i think that is a very
good point regarding early release
i'm not sure what the current
system is that the department of
education does for addressing that issue
or how school districts might address
that situation if it's only them there's
enabling legislation for that that's a
good question for the department
thank you very much are there further
questions we have others who'd like to
speak on this bill as well
thank you very much representative thank
you
okay
uh jennifer if you could keep it not 10
certainly mr chairman
good morning um chairman lad vice
chairman cordelia and esteem members of
the education committee i'm
representative jennifer rhodes i
represent cheshire district 15 which is
the plateau district winchester richmond
marble swansea and troy
i'm here today to represent
miss tomela's seventh grade social
studies class
on the days that i'm not here
i'm actually a substitute in the
winchester school district
on tuesdays i float to cover any special
education meetings
one particular day
we were discussing how a bill actually
becomes law with this particular class
i was asked about bills of interest and
i did remember about this particular
lunch bill
i would like to give credit to the
representative for writing this bill
because i can assure you that the entire
school is watching this particular
hearing and it has caused such a stir
carter thinks we should not do it
because we will have a longer day and if
we have practice for sports it will make
willow thinks this bill is a good
idea i'm sorry
she does not think this bill is a good
idea
so forth about the sports and longer
longer days of the year
emma thinks we should have extended
lunch times because
because if you're at the end of the line
you may only have about five minutes to
eat your food
grayson is in favor of this bill
because he believes we need more time
for lunch so we can eat all of our food
so we won't starve
also if the bill if the governor can
hear this bill he wants it to be signed
however i'm going to change my hat for a
minute and i'm going to speak for the
the biggest question we have about this
legislation is how is this going to be
executed if the person at the beginning
of the line
is sitting for 20 minutes or what about
the person at the end of the line when
exactly is this 20 minutes supposed to
start
furthermore in elementary school
recess is considered educational
instruction however in middle school in
high school it is not
therefore any time that you have to put
for anything else you do have to extend
your day in this case you wouldn't be
able to extend your day you would
actually have to extend the school year
um
another point is
reimbursable meals
there's with the federal government
there's offer versus serve
so when a student goes to the lunch line
they have to have a minimum of three
things on their tray for to be
considered reimbursable
furthermore they can't just have a
vegetable they have to have an option
between a vegetable cooked or a
vegetable raw if they have fruit they
have to have an option are they going to
have
an orange are they going to have actual
juice
furthermore from when i was in school
and i'm assuming most of you we have had
what i call the nutrition evolution
i remember the breakfast program coming
out is a pilot program
in a school that i substitute the
students are offered breakfast whenever
they walk in in the morning then around
10 o'clock they're offered snack there's
usually about three choices in the
basket which is also delivered to their
classrooms then they go to lunch and
then after lunch they have another snack
i can assure you these students are not
going to starve by any stretch of the
imagination
the
the 11 to 2.
currently our school is starting lunch
at 10 45 normally it is 11 o'clock
however this is a coveted problem this
is not a lunch problem
so we would ask if you're going to do
anything please do not put any more
shackles on the schools as far as their
time frames
only going to make it more difficult for
the administration to have to
i guess execute this bill
so with that being said
i do believe that the seventh graders in
the administration of the winchester
school district would ask do you find
this bill in exceeding the legislate
thank you for your time well thank you
very much representative and we welcome
the kids from winchester who hopefully
are listening
and getting an education and how things
occur in their own state in terms of how
a bill becomes a law
uh are there any questions of the
representative
not seeing in hands thank you very much
thank you for your time all have a great
day
representative smith
from hebrew
thank you mr chair and
it's for everybody because some of the
questions seem to be if we pass this
bill we're going to have to have longer
lunch breaks and the school day will
the
the time it takes to go through the line
the time it takes to pick your food all
of those things add and take away from
that 20 minute time that you are allowed
to eat
and both
the
american pediatric association and the
cdc recommend that students have
20 minutes to actually eat their lunch
not 20 minutes including standing in
line
i
spoke to a constituent about this who
just went on and on about her son who
did sports had to eat his lunch so
quickly that by the time it came time to
do his after-school activity she had to
bring him another sandwich to eat
because he just didn't get enough at
lunch time the fourth graders at
plymouth elementary school when they
came to visit the state house they had a
nice long discussion about this bill
also and all but one were in favor of
passing it
i know when my daughter was in school
her lunch she got on the bus at seven
o'clock her lunch break was at 10 30 but
she didn't get home until four
so that whole period of time in between
was a long break for kids to not be able
to eat their lunch
and um
the one of the recommendations from the
cdc is having recess before lunch so the
kids get some of that steam worked off
and then when they go to sit down to eat
they're a little more relaxed and able
to enjoy their lunch
as uh before i was a
state rep i was all i've been a
nutritionist for
30 or 40 years
and
children's diets in school
leave a lot to be desired when they
don't eat the fruit that is in the lunch
on the lunch line but they just eat the
pizza
and
having a little extra time to eat
enables them to get more nutrition out
of their food which will help them
overall in their studies
and in
all the activities that they do
i don't want to say any more
representative deshay
said it all i think but i do wanna i did
bring handouts on uh ways to
so students can have enough time to eat
lunch
and what is seat time are schools
providing enough and this is a handout
from the cdc
and although they're a little
controversial the american pediatric
academy also agrees
with the precept of this bill and i
think when we get into the situation of
what happens with when we let people out
early or they come in late i think those
are things schools deal with all the
time it's not that we're asking for the
lunch hour to be extended just that the
time in that 20 minute 30 minutes
20 minutes is allowed for eating and
that means just streamlining some
processes along the way
i have one other comment nothing to do
with the bill
when the person is giving testimony
speaks and has the red light on it goes
out through the speaker so everyone can
hear it but it appears that when they
turn it off i couldn't hear anyone in
the
on the committee so i think that their
mics don't come through the speaker when
this is turned off that's just my
observation so i don't know you can
figure it out but thank you and i can
take any questions i don't know if it's
a daisy chain of links i don't know i
know it's really kind of crazy are there
any uh questions for the speaker
not seeing hands thank you very much
anya
good morning chairman lad members of the
house ed committee for the record my
name is megan tuttle president of nea
new hampshire we represent over 17 000
educators across the state
i'm also an 18-year social studies
teacher 8th grade i had lunch duty many
times over those 18 years from 6th grade
up through 8th grade and a mom of three
boys in public schools in concord i'm
coming to you today in support of house
bill
1058 legislation that would add a
lunchtime
and seated meal time requirement for
schools in new hampshire as educators we
know that there are many factors that
can negatively affect or i'm sorry
influence a child's ability to learn and
be productive at school including a lack
of nutrition which leads to a lack of
focus among other issues
therefore not eating or not eating
enough something we should seek to
prevent in addition to improving the
quality of food available to our
students i can say
my own three kids come home many times
they're third grade fifth grade in ninth
grade three boys um so they're eating
every hour if they can
but they're coming home constantly
telling me there's not enough time to
eat at lunch and to you know keep giving
more food so they can have it
recent study published in the journal of
child nutrition and management indicated
insufficient time is a key reason for
not participating in the school lunch
program
another study published in 2021 used a
randomized clinical trial to study the
effects of longer seeded lunchtime on
food consumption and waste in elementary
and middle school aged children
the results showed that more eating time
is associated with more consumption of
fruits and vegetables in this crossover
trial of 241 lunch observations from 38
children
20 minutes of seated lunch time were
associated with significantly more
consumption and significantly less waste
of fruits and vegetables compared with
10 minutes of seeded lunch time
research conducted at the harvard t chan
school of public health confirms the
intuition that increasing lunch length
would boost consumption
the study published in the journal of
the academy of nutrition and dietetics
concluded that students in rush lunch
periods eat less of every meal component
kids who are given less than 20 minutes
to eat consume 13 less of their entree
10 percent less of their milk 12 percent
less of their vegetable compared with
those who had at least 25 minutes
consequently the study also found more
food waste among kids who had less time
to eat dr
julia cohen stated as part of the study
that research shows that children who
eat healthier foods learn better and
have fewer disciplinary issues
in addition to the study cited here the
american academy of pediatrics is also
pushing for at least 20 minutes of
seated time
finally there's even evidence from one
study published in the southern economic
journal in 2014 that an increased lunch
length reduces the probability a child
is overweight
our students have a tremendous number of
environmental influences on their lives
and one of the things we learned during
a period of extended remote learning is
that in-person school is a positive one
however being back at school does not
leave behind all the challenges kids
face these days we can help ensure the
lack of an inadequate meal time and all
the effects that come with it not be a
factor that's inhibiting our kids from
learning in the classroom and being
healthy
i asked the committee take a step
forward for our students on this
important issue and find house bill 1058
ought to pass
thank you and i will take any questions
uh thank you and if you have written
testimony maybe you could pass that up
to our clerk thank you any questions
from the committee
scene none thank you very much thank you
and i believe our final uh speaker for
good morning
for the record my name is nancy vaughn
government relations director for the
american heart association in new
hampshire and thank you very much for
taking the time
to not only hear testimony on this
important bill but also the questions
that you are asking
so the american heart association does
support this bill and we do urge that
that you pass it
basically we do believe that expanding
on the amount of time children have to
eat their their lunch meal
is something that's very important for
children to um to
take in the nutrition that they need and
and perform academically to that at
their highest standard one comment that
wasn't necessarily made by others that i
will
give us a verbal testimony students from
families with low income receive more of
their food and nutrition intake from
school meals
when they don't have time to eat
and particularly the the time it takes
to chew fresh fruits and vegetables that
we really prefer them to be choosing
that they will be missing out on these
important nutrients perhaps for the
entire day if most of their nutrients do
come from from school lunch
and or school breakfast
and again there is science that children
who
who eat more nutritious diets tend to
perform better academically so in
addition to the other testimony that was
given today that is in my written
testimony i will conclude and if you do
have any questions i'm happy to try to
answer them
scene none thank you very much thank you
and i was mistaken we do have one more
thank you mr chairman not your fault my
for the record my name is jerry fruit
i'm the associate executive director for
the new hampshire school administrators
association
happy new year it's my first appearance
before the committee won't be my last i
can pretty much guarantee that so
i will be brief
representative cornell appreciate your
and can relate to your experience in
middle school cafeterias as an assistant
principal and principal for 14 years
um
yeah 20 minutes can seem like a lifetime
uh and representative baum i appreciate
your
concerns as well as as a systems leader
and person who helped negotiate
collective bargaining agreements and
guaranteeing lunch time for staff and
working conditions for cafeteria workers
can appreciate your concern about
the financial potential financial
ramifications of this through collective
bargaining
and certainly appreciate the sponsors
for bringing this issue forward
being opposed to something like this
would be akin to being opposed to apple
pie and motherhood so we're not going to
oppose this
but we are concerned with a couple of
factors
the time frame involved of 11 o'clock to
is
a little problematic and we appreciate
the sponsor's willingness to perhaps
entertain an amendment to adjust that i
did a very quick unscientific poll of
some of our members
at a meeting recently there were about
20 members in the room and i asked how
many
districts would be impacted by
this time frame of 11 o'clock to 2
o'clock and over half of the hands in
the room went up so there was a concern
that
school schedules would have to be
adjusted therein brings my our second
concern
by the time this legislation makes it
through the process
and
we would have concerns about
the implementation timeline of it being
put into effect for next year
school schedules will be developed by
mid-may
student schedules will be developed by
mid-may school budgets for next year are
basically in the process of final
approval now
so we would respectfully request that
should this
move forward that the timeline be
extended so that school districts
because local school districts will be
impacted
through student schedules
through fiscal impact
through potentially bus schedules and
length of school day
we would need some runway time to in
each local district to be able to
implement this very well intended
student-centered piece of legislation
which obviously we feel
is in
the best interest of children
so
with that
i will stop
and be happy to address any questions
thank you for
your first appearance
um
thank you mr chair
thank you sir for taking our questions
um
do i understand you correctly that it
might be preferable to have in this bill
a time
component
that is flexible so it wouldn't
necessarily have to be
11 to 2 or something like that it could
be
10 15 to
some short but a two-hour time frame
would that satisfy
the needs that you were hearing from
your various uh colleagues thank you for
your for your question representative
ford uh and i believe it was
representative baum that alluded to the
space issues involved too and being able
to service
students in a
you know some schools a number of them
in this state have a multi-purpose room
where they serve school lunch and they
also conduct physical education classes
and
if i'm not mistaken it may be later on
this afternoon that this committee is
going to hear something about extended
physical education classes uh
i will speak with you at one o'clock
about all of those things
um
but uh
yes i think um
schools need flexibility to implement
anything like this because it's again
it's different in nashua than it is in
chester or than it is in up in the north
country where uh you know
grade k to eight
play basketball and then they sit down
and eat lunch and then they
have a play in the same room all within
the span of two hours so
okay uh jerry thank you uh thank you
just quick question i just want to be
clear you said at the beginning you're
not opposing what um
are you not support you you didn't make
a position you said we were talking
about apple pie and they probably had
that after lunch my question is what is
the what is the formal position of the
nhsa
we would support it with the proper
amendments and with the proper in its
current form we could not support it
because it would be it limits
any further questions seen none thank
you very much
and i will close the uh
hearing on uh this bill
and um do we have cards for the next
bill
we'll just get those cards and move
directly into the
oh
we'll
move
right into
house bill 1261 prohibiting the use of
native american mascots in public
schools colleges and universities
i do not have a card from the
prime sponsor
evidently they are not here
uh you can fill out the card afterwards
that's fine
so i will call upon
for the record
my name is representative cannon
and i represent stratford county
thank you for letting me speak mr
what do you envision
when you see a native american mascot
image
on a football helmet
around a jersey
or when you see someone dressed like a
native american
as they try to imitate
a native dance
on a sports field
do you see a native american physician
police officer engineer
movie star
an entrepreneur or a service man or
woman
most likely you're thinking of an indian
brave wearing a headband with a feather
stuck in it
sitting on a horse looking out over the
plains
if you were a native american youth
what would you see
would you see
reminders of the days
when indians were feared
while they fought to keep the land that
they lived on
would you see
a future for themselves
or would they see
people making fun of indians
and disrespecting their clothing
and ritual dances
does their school
have a native american
program or classes to learn the meaning
behind the use of those mascots or logos
or of
themselves
worth noting
all new hampshire sports
names
were not made with north american
input
we know that native american youth
experience the highest rates of suicide
among young people
studies have shown that negative
stereotypes harmful to indian sports
mascots
are known to play a role in perpetuating
the feelings of inadequacy among native
youth
we are seeing many organizations across
the nation reconsidering their use of
native american images and names
including
in 2001 the us commission of civil
rights concluded that natal native
american references in sports
quote
whether mascots and their performances
logos or names
are disrespectful
and offensive to american indians and
others who are offended by such
stereotyping
unquote
and
quote are particularly inappropriate
insensitive in light of the long history
of force forced assimilation
that american indian people have endured
the american psychological association
has come out
to say that they let them know that they
passed a resolution calling for the
immediate retirement of american indian
mascots image imagery citing potential
negative effects it may have on the
mental health and psychological behavior
americans sociological association
called for discontinued use of native
american nicknames logos and mascots and
sports
stating that social science scholarship
has demonstrated that the continued use
of native american nicknames
logos and mascots
in sports
harm native american people
in psychological educational
new hampshire state board of education
whereas the new hampshire state board of
education is aware that various north
american organizations
state and local officials and private
citizens find the use of native american
mascots
and symbols within our public schools
the board
flagged that the detrimental effect
on the achievement
education
self-concept and self-esteem
of
american indian students
sends an improper message to everyone
of the true meaning and spirit of being
in light of this
new hampshire
still continues to have indian sports
mascots
all heritage
all heritages
cultures races and religion have the
right to be treated with dignity
it is important
that we be culturally sensitive
to educate everyone
working within the new hampshire school
and educational system
no matter how well the meaning of their
intentions
that their actions may be offensive and
harmful to some
we don't have
any north american tribes
headquartered in new hampshire we do
have
many people from the abenaki
tribe who will speak during
retirement of native american mascots is
nothing it's not just here in new
hampshire it's across the country
it is being considered in states
businesses
and by sports teams
are some states with large
native american
presence
and schools with native american
educational programs who may allow some
of those schools to use native american
imagery
native american
families
from the abenaki people
are really concerned
to note
there are no educational programs in our
schools
that discuss
native american topics or
that people
compared to compared north american
the fighting irish
that no tradition
in a statement
made
it's worth noting
that there is no comparison between
notre dame's nickname
and mascot
and the indian and warrior names in
mascots used by other institutions
such as the nfl team formerly known as
the redskins
the state's statement also noted
none of these institutions
were founded or named
by native americans who sought to
highlight their heritage by using names
and symbols
this morning when i was getting dressed
and i saw
a sweater i'd worn for many years
a white sweater and it was it was
really a wonderful sweater
back then
but as i looked at it today
it was worn and tattered
it was something i would not wear in
public
because it didn't apply it's not
something i could wear here
and the reason i mention this is because
many of the mascots that we have today
are old and outdated
the message is not something that people
want to share in public and are and are
embarrassing to the native americans in
our communities
so they don't wear it
just as i'm not wearing that sweater
over the past two years
we here in the legislature
enacted legislation
to encourage us all to treat each other
respectfully as equals
this is one of the reasons why i'm
bringing this legislation forward
we need to treat
our native american brothers and sisters
with
respect and as equals
we need to let
all of our children
learn in an environment that accepts
them
for who they are today
i urge you
to vote ought to pass
to save the lives
of native american
youth in our state
thank you
thank you very much
uh are there any questions
uh representative baum
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
i agree with this but what about other
ethnics
i mean shouldn't this be covering
everybody like you had said all need to
school changed their name because it
wasn't right
the
florida state seminoles they're called
seminoles because the name is licensed
by the seven-year-old tribe
so should that be changed so my concern
is other ethics are also good to see for
example vikings i mean that's the same
type of
situation so
what about everybody
well in the case i'll take them
specifically in the seminoles and some
other members which may do the same
thing seminose is a very large native
american organization in florida and
they do have
schools
that have educational programs to
educate the students in those schools so
their use of
of logos and names
is appropriate the same thing happens in
colorado and other states and there's
legislation moving forward in those
states that has exceptions as long as
the native american organizations and
the school systems have worked together
to agree to the use of those logos
case of the vikings
same thing with patriots and other other
names they are
a generalization of
organizations that we don't necessarily
use today there's no patriots tribe
there are no vikings tribes
they they are educate they are
in in a way
they're
organizations that we teach to our youth
we teach about them
we don't teach our youth about native
americans
in our communities or even across
test test
press
yes representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking this question
do you know how many schools or
organizations in the state currently use
native american images or
for mascots i've been made aware of
eight
thank you
any further questions uh represent likus
i am curious where you got your
information that no schools taught about
native american culture
while i personally didn't go to school
here i know when i went to school that
was definitely part of
history geography
etc etc social studies basically
and in most cases
native americans are mentioned
we don't have any in-depth programs or
educational classes that talk about
native americans specifically
in our state
i'm almost afraid of touching my
my background in this will perhaps not
be surprising when i indicate that i
very much support this
because i was once made a relative of
the in the lakota tradition
uh in response for advocating exactly
this kind of
response as well as the inclusion of
having people on faculties and on
organizations and providing leadership
that in the upper midwest
one of the things though that i would
ask that you consider following
representative bone's statement is that
perhaps
we could
allow the in doing this bill allow the
native americans to provide the
leadership
to go back to attacking all of those
forms of
ethnic slurs and denigrations i mean our
language gives us our own history
whether we like it or not
do is anyone not understand what i mean
when i say someone is a a a
jew
a chief
all these things go on and on and on
we've got them for almost every ethnic
group that came here because they're a
way of designating otherness not one of
us
and what you're advocating is saying
we're all one of us right and not not
not lincoln and our symbols and so forth
we've pretty much gotten it to where
it's not acceptable to use those words
in our language excuse me representative
ford do you have a question yes my
question is isn't it
about time or would you agree that it is
about time
to do this symbolically
and that's why i brought this bill
forward you will hear more discussion
from other speakers after me
and uh you will hear of the of the
challenges they have faced especially
with the language we use
thank you miss chair and thank you
representative canada for being here uh
the fsu seminole
issue i was going to bring up but
representative baum did that and i
thought you addressed it well my
question
uh
is in a follow-up or two if i may
um here in new hampshire uh dartmouth uh
used to be known as the indians uh do
you know how that came about
i am not sure
uh if i may then uh dartmouth was
founded in 1769 by eleazar wheelock as a
school to
primarily in
educate native americans indians
indigenous people
even today dartmouth allows special
carve outs for
native american indian indigenous people
to go to dartmouth dartmouth was founded
for indians and the athletic teams were
known as indians to celebrate that
dartmouth heritage
when dartmouth changed to the big green
uh
this is a question dartmouth changed the
big green
uh indian chiefs native americans
indigenous people from all over came to
hanover to argue that dartmouth should
continue to honor its native american
heritage and history by honoring
indians as as they used to
so
my question following that up is uh
sports illustrated did a poll that
showed 80 percent of native americans
uh savored and relished and supported
the the the way that teams honor once
they get rid of some of the
superfluous stuff the way the teams
honor
native americans so my question is
do you think dartmouth uh
was disrespecting indians by selling by
is the indians themselves
celebrating the institution by honoring
they changed the name
in 1974.
it is now
2022.
the
thoughts that were used back back then
as far as
discussing this topic are not
necessarily
the same as they are today
and when we hear the native americans
new hampshire native americans
talk about
their thoughts of today
you will hear
that they're not happy with our current
use
of mascots that are supposed to reflect
who they are
any further questions seeing none thank
you very much for being here thank you
for listening to me and i will pass in a
card
thank you
thank you very much i'm representative
timothy oregon from stratfor county
district six with the towns of durham
and madbury and um
happily unh has never had a problem with
its uh
mascot which is the uh which is the
wildcat and um i i i'm a former resident
of hanover i did work for
dartmouth college uh while for a time
while i was living in hanover and um
this that was
in the air when the when there were the
big green and certainly um
dartmouth does not lack for school
spirit it doesn't lack for loyalty from
its students and alumni it's a very
spirited place even with the big green
so the former indian uh
mascot was uh was uh
unnecessary you know they're uh
you know they're just as great a group
it's just a great community with the big
green is with the indians and they
actually
um hanover actually still has an issue
with the they're one of the eight
schools that uh
they've got a questionable nickname
which was the marauders um
i think and um i'm also uh
before that i was born in south in
indiana where notre dame is my
father's a notre dame late father no
name alumnus and i feel a little bit
conflicted about the fighting irish logo
partially because it's a misnomer
the school is actually founded by french
priests not irish priests but uh there's
a difference between
quote unquote other ethnics
and and uh and
and the uh native tribes um indians as
as uh
they're often commonly referred to which
um
which is that you know we
you know the white people uh came here
we
took their land we uh
killed many you know we
many cases embarked on genocide um and
it's uh
and we've often sort of written them out
of history especially out of uh
recent history but you know they're
still they survived they're still very
much there they're still uh just as uh
you know there's still a very strong
force here
here on the north american continent and
in new hampshire and also many ways the
stewards of the land that we've all
benefited from so like we
the colonists certainly benefited from
what they've done uh previously to the
lands i think um
so i think
using
using native american mascots it tends
to turn them into cartoons and there is
sort of a difference between that and uh
you know
using some other uh the name of some
other ethnic group like the fighting
irish or the uh
hofstra flying dutchman or
those
or things like that and um
also point out that when you uh when you
when you change the name you know with
sports teams it has very little effect
has no effect whatsoever on their
performance the uh
for example the washington redskins
became the washington football team and
they actually uh
although they missed the playoffs this
year they've actually been playing
better since they changed the name so
apparently
the success they had the past was
not
not because of the nickname and not
because of you know the cartoon on the
side of their defensive cartoon on the
side of their helmet so um
and i'm sure we'll probably see the same
with the
cleveland guardians they're probably uh
i mean they're not one of the top teams
in the american league but they probably
i guarantee they will probably
play just as well this year as the
guardians as they did under their
previous nickname so like they're uh
and they've had a lot of great teams in
the past and they did not succeed
because of you know the offensive
cartoon on their baseball caps it was uh
for other reasons and um
so
so i think probably so anyways i think
this is a this is a uh
you know this is a good bill it's um
and
and i know you'll hear about the
traditions of high schools and colleges
but those can evolve a lot quicker than
um than we
than we than we think they can and also
some sort of cheapens you know the
status of uh
you know the the uh the traditions of a
you know indigenous nation or tribe as
they're often called to like you know
equate them with the traditions of a
high school or a college you know that's
not that it's not that it's not
important time of your life but there's
a little bit
a little bit of difference between
um
your identity as a member of your school
for a few years that that you were there
and um then there is uh
then there is you know being part of a
nation that's been around for ten
thousand you know it's been i've been
here for thousands of years so i i
urge you to urge you to pass your bill i
know it's difficult sometimes especially
in rochester where we had a controversy
a couple years ago
they tried to rebrand their raiders as a
pirate and i guess the pirate is also
sort of an inaccurate historical
stereotype
they tried to rebrand their teams of
raiders and unfortunately the old indian
uh
the old indian logos still like uh
managed to like resurface and people you
know unofficially started uh using them
so there's uh
that community will have to come up with
solution to to that issue that's um but
so i i
i urge you to so i would i would
appreciate the i would urge you to pass
this bill and um thank you
any uh questions for the representative
oh sure representative
since you brought up the indian slash
guardians which were my home team
the indian slash guardians oh yes
um
my understanding is that
most of the native peoples of the area
were very upset to lose that name
because they were proud of it
um
i just wondered yeah i just wondered if
you were aware of that since you brought
them up i do not know that i actually do
know the history of how the nickname
came to be adopted um
so in the 1890s actually that was a
previous franchisee i
i think you answered yes so i i've not
seen those polls um so i can't
any further questions representative
moffatt
thank you mr thank you representative
morgan for taking my question and maybe
a possible follow-up
uh would you believe that when i was in
college i had a date with a
call student from hanover and i asked
her what was a marauder and she as you
said
as a pirate
which leads me to my question
marauders
are not necessarily indigenous the re
belmont is the red raiders which is not
necessarily
indigenous and there are a number of
schools that are the warriors which is
uh as representative cannon said with
regard to vikings or fighting iris is
kind of a broad generic warriors could
be greek warriors so you name it
so
i
my question is you're all concerned
about the the heavy hand of the state
coming and telling belmont they can't be
the warriors or winner or the red
raiders winner kind of can't be the
warriors hanover can be the marauders
none of these names are specific to
indigenous peoples
do you think that is a possible first
amendment issue with the state telling
schools
uh
how they can cloud their their teams
well it's not a first amendment issue um
so it was there's no freedom of the
press violation there the uh and
secretly speaking school district isn't
even a person so it doesn't have uh free
speech rights but that's uh so i'm
not concerned not that concerned about
it and i mean i don't really know
i'm not an expert in the history of how
hanover high school got its nickname or
belmont high school
thank you thanks
uh any further questions
seeing none thank you very much uh next
and i would ask maybe uh you could
shorten your testimony from
what you indicated you needed on the
card
i'm
glad to be present here in the
legislative office building here
served here for two years as a
legislator so i know the challenges you
have
this is
uh because you want me to limit my
remarks
um i could take each one of the
questions so far and you could go into
detail
about the changes the name changes and
that sort of thing first of all i want
i grew up in the
cowboy and indian era where we ran
around with cap guns
and we ran through the woods chasing the
indians to kill them because that's the
way it was presented in the movies so we
adopted that
new hampshire had a
law passed
uh in this when it was in the process of
wanting to remove all indian resistance
to come to the settlement of settle
settlements throughout the state where
it passed a law
that all
that they would pay a bounty for any
indian scalp
and that bounty went up in value
over
time
so
there was a specific effort to eliminate
the last of the native peoples here
in new hampshire so that it could be
occupied by white europeans without
threat of attack
but in the 21st century
i
was an educator at lebanon where it was
the raiders i taught a course on
in social studies on uh native americans
but it never really crossed my mind to
make the connection
between the course and the fact they
were call red raiders
so uh i was given this t-shirt
at my 75th birthday
five years ago
uh didn't really cross my mind then but
as i got involved with the uh
indigenous group at unh and i began to
do my own research to learn about the
history of native americans
in new hampshire
my mind changed that we needed at ins at
rochester spalding high school to do
away with the red raider images as
portrayed here because they're
inaccurate anyway to any there
um
and to substitute something in its place
at a choice for the school
however in our most recent debate with
the school board on this
[Music]
i've got the notes here
the population came forward
essentially obviously divided it was a
very emotional argument from those who
wanted to continue the red raider name
why
because that's what's there that's
what's been there that's how you
represent your school uh spirit of core
and then there are those that are more
sensitive to
uh
the battle that's going on both in
canada because i live in canada in the
summertime so i'm intimately involved
with it here and here in the united
states to gain equal representation for
indigenous peoples
and something that is not shaped in
these types of images
new hampshire uh department of education
has on the books the recommendation to
do away with these images it's been
there for years do you know that right
right
but
they have no enforcement power
all the states around you have
put in the enforcement power of passing
this law
we're asking you to do the same thing
even though in the absence you are the
only state
or province
in north america that has no reservation
to speak for itself
because new hampshire was successful in
completely eliminating the presence of
the native
peoples
saint francis in quebec
or melted into the indian groups in
maine or into vermont
so it's an emotional issue i hear it in
your questions of support possibly of
the indians at uh
at dartmouth
or these other groups need to be
represented this is focused this bill is
focused
on dealing specifically with
the issue of
doing away
with characterization
group of people
one of the most
articulate speakers at the debate in
rochester was a 16 year old native
student
who objected to this
and i'll be the first to admit it went
right over the head of the majority of
the school board
so you represent
the state of new hampshire
the need to address
where those
at the
need guidance
and so that's what we're asking you to
provide is guidance by passing this law
to bring new hampshire up to the 21st
century
any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
see none thank you very much for being
here
mr chairman members of the committee uh
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak with you all today
my name is frank knack i'm the policy
director with the aclu of new hampshire
and i'm here in strong support of this
legislation
first i'd like to thank representative
cannon for bringing this important bill
um i don't want to um just repeat what
she would represent canada has already
said
uh just to reiterate that this bill is
about stopping public schools from
perpetuating negative and damaging
stereotypes about indigenous people
and as has already been mentioned this
has been
reinforced by our own state board of
education by the united states
commission on civil rights by the
american psychiatric association
we should be focused on ensuring that
new hampshire schools foster safe
inclusive learning environments for all
students and heavy native american
mascots undermines that core principle
that we should be all striving towards
so thank you so much i have testimony if
it'd be appropriate to hand out
yes thank you
any questions
see none thank you very much
uh next is uh
deniselle and paul poiloit
walton
sorry i've if i pronounced your name
incorrectly
kwai needle bach in delaware sin denise
julio sagamo wood with sin paul
puglio sagamo kawasaki band of pentacle
gabanaki
hello friends my name is denise puglio
i'm the head female speaker and this is
paul puglio the head mill speaker of the
kawasaki band of the pentacle gabanaki
located in odanaku nippy which
translates to the place of the narrowing
waters now known as alton new hampshire
we are here today to discuss
hb 1261 and we urge you to support this
bill and its passage in the banning of
the use of native american mascots
paul's going to
hand you some written testimony that we
have done
so we can go on about
the psychological effects bullying
um cultural issues
um you know we the list is long of why
um
indigenous p you know indigenous mascots
should be removed but at the end of the
day
you all banned the use of human mascots
rsa
193-4-0 known as the discrimination in
public schools law
banned the use of human mascots the law
basically states you cannot disparage a
race or uplift a race more than any
other race in that school and that's
exactly what mascots do so no matter
what side of this bill you're on
whether you're for mascots whether
you're against mascots it's already been
banned in the state
this bill is just codifying that ban
and it is making it clear to the
institutions within that state that
human mascots will not be tolerated
anymore
for the record
you may not have a federal tribe here
but in 1995
our band petitioned the federal
government we're on record with the
bureau of indian affairs
the
secretary of state and the attorney
general of this state know we are
headquartered here in alton and it's
been on record uh for quite a few years
so the idea that there's no indian
tribes as you guys would like to say is
false we are headquartered here we've
always been here and we've been kind of
invisible to most of you
as you can tell by the testimony today
i mean we could answer a lot of your
questions i think the package we've
handed out really covers a lot of the
history how mascots were actually
evolved
out of the boston tea party
uh you know the raid on the on the ships
for the tea
back and that became a real uh changing
moment in our country where
indigenous imagery was used for the
benefit of politics
and that evolved into fraternal
organizations and a lot of hobbyists and
other things
i can answer the question about
dartmouth dartmouth
is really a
a very difficult history
unknown to most people
uh they kind of glorified indigenous
people they were smoking rooms like this
in dartmouth were where scenes were
painted of indigenous women in bailly
any clothing
and that's where the boys used to sit
and drink and you know smoke the cigars
dartmouth had to change their philosophy
they were in indian school
but they really didn't honor any
indigenous people in this state they
never did
they
when everybody says oh well they brought
in indians in to endorse things at
dartmouth they never engaged anybody in
new england
if you actually look at the record
you'll see how many uh how few people
dartmouth actually graduated with
indigenous descent it wasn't until after
the retirement of the mascots and the
removal of the offensive sexually
explicit murals that were done in the
school halls um that dartmouth decided
to take the bull by the horns and
actually fulfill its its initial contact
and then so they started offering
scholarships and other um
benefits to uh uplift the indigenous
population the abner and the related
tribes in new england still are
marginalized by dotnet even today so i
don't want to go down to you know i
don't want to get into the weeds on that
but that's another sore subject with us
mascots are not just a problem it's all
the other imagery
things of violence tomahawks uh tomahawk
chops uh
uh cheerleaders dressing and skimpy are
tired trying to
make some kind of costume that looks
like an indigenous thing these are the
things we see still going on right and
these all be all these behaviors um
contribute to the missing and murdered
indigenous women problem that we're
suffering across this nation and canada
we are disappearing by the thousands
because we're considered sub-human
so we sit here today praying that you
decide to see us as human beings and we
and stop the use of these mascots
i mean if you go through what we've
given you for some handout information
you'll see the 2002
uh department of education memorandum
what we think is it should have been uh
made into law back then in 2002 and it's
a shame that it's 20 years later we're
still talking about the subject matter
will it be resistance there's always
resistance i'm like dave miller i'm in
my my 70s he's probably 80 now i can't
remember how old he is we've seen a lot
of things change socially and racially
you know we we baby boomers after world
war ii a lot of things which we accepted
back then are not acceptable today and
we would never even imagine it you we've
heard about the seminoles that's great
the seminoles get actually financial
benefit by using their name most other
tribes do not have that relationship
just so you understand
that there are groups out there that
would love to say mascots are great but
every time we investigate what goes on
in these schools
they'll say chief so-and-so came to our
town in 1970 and said it was all right
we do the research and these people were
not indigenous people at all they were
just people that were playing the game
and then trying to convince the town it
was all right so we found after we've
done a lot of research on all the the
background of these towns
there's is a false sense that they did
things right they didn't they looked for
the easy way out
we worked with uh locally here merrimack
uh valley
to high school
school would i cut it
um both have have had their names their
mascots changed
when akanet is in the process of
creating a video dot mini documentary
about that process change and about how
it affected the community and about why
it was necessary so this is about
education it's about the betterment of
society and it's about treating people
as equals
so we're going to stop here because we
could go on for hours because we get
really emotional when it comes to the
subject but we ask you today to pass
and we don't see where they would be
discord on either side where this is
already a lot in effect today
thank you just for the record though we
do not impose our will on towns
we are usually react to uh petitions
from students and then we come into the
into discussion thank you very much any
questions
representative lakers please
yeah i just the last thing that you said
um
that the students petition is that not
a reasonable way to go about this i just
hadn't heard that until you just said it
students petitioned
in all the schools that we interact with
um and so the students come forward
requesting that the mascot be removed we
meet with school boards and other
interested parties and have the long
lengthy emotional discussions
the last
time we had this conversation was in
rochester at spaulding high school a
student came forward because she was
being bullied
and went in front of the school board
making the request the school board told
her to go talk to her guidance counselor
that they don't tolerate bullying and
that there's nothing they could do for
her
thank you so it was frustrating but i
can also state that
i do know of at least two students where
schools within the state had to pay to
ship them outside their district because
of the school mascots and their bullying
thank you thank you very much um
yes
please thank you thank you schedule
thank you for being your comment in the
question possible follow-up uh i i've
taught
yes question uh
is that given that there is a difference
between symbols and nicknames and
mascots and and i keep hearing mascot
what do you say to the folks and i said
earlier sports illustrated polls said 80
percent of native americans in their
polls supported the the way that symbols
and nicknames not mascots which you keep
referring to but symbols and nicknames
honor
uh affiliations with indigenous people
given there are so many people not
activists but so many native americans
who are not here but who
celebrate this connection what do you
say to them
my question is is who's taking the poll
and who are they polling and are they
registered with an indigenous tribe or
are they just claiming descendancy
um there are a lot of varying factors
within this
and um i ha have not seen the poll i
don't know where the poll was conducted
i don't know who the poll was conducted
with was it just with sports stands of
these particular sports teams
so i mean there's a lot of questions so
i question the authenticity of the poll
thank you very much
um thank you
no further questions uh thank you very
much for being here and testifying okay
delaney great thanks uh and i'll call
hi my name is jonathan weinberg i'm a
member of the concord school board
however i'm speaking my capacity as an
individual i want to illuminate some
ideas actually that was in reference to
the sports illustrated poll
it was taken
from 504
respondents
about 51 said they were pro football
fans and they were all self-identified
members of native american tribes
uh moreover it is easy to say where we
get statistics from there's another
berkeley poll that says about 70 of
individuals
oppose
mascots and symbols so
just like any group of individuals
individuals are not a monolith and also
we need to make sure we
recognize where sources come from
i
think it is beyond time that we pass
house bill 1261
as a member of a local school district i
cannot imagine
going to school and
having derogatory symbols uh radiate and
permeate through the buildings so i urge
you to pass this legislation thank you
thank you for being here any questions
for the speaker
see none thank you very much
and i will call uh
our final i think i'm correct this time
kristen fercilius
hi thank you for squeezing me and i'll
be really quick i'm kristen for still
can you hear me okay with my mask on uh
kristen forsylias i'm actually
representing community church of durham
in new hampshire i'm from lean new
hampshire
just because i haven't heard any voices
of youth i wanted to just relay
messages from our youth group we talked
about this bill last night at our
meeting they strongly support it
and i'm just going to read a statement
here so they want school mascots in
their state to represent their
generation
one that they see as respectful
compassionate and inclusive and one that
they can be proud of
this bill is for them
and the type of future and legacy they
want to be a part of so i just wanted to
put that in the record
i also
wanted to respond to
the comment
can't students this just happened from
students petition and i just think of
what a burden we're asking for youth who
are already going through so much these
days in schools with kovid to now put
another responsibility on them and i ask
you to instead see yourselves as models
of what we can be and uh so
be somebody the students can look up to
and see what their future is and how
they
would like that their legacy to be
remembered so we urge you to please
support and pass 1261.
thank you
thank you any questions
see none thank you
um
late entry
be brief please yes
um thank you my name is louise spencer
from concord new hampshire
i i attended dartmouth
and
was there in
the early 80s when the
indian symbol
was
attempt there was an attempt to bring it
back
into use
and
the native students native indian
students
native american students that were at
dartmouth
were very
originally in 1969
the students
there were native students who
originally
opposed the
native american symbol the school had
only educated in its first 200 years
about a dozen native americans
so
i'm not aware that there was a lot of
effort from outside
groups to try to persuade the school to
keep
the native american symbol thank you
i think that will
end this hearing
and i'll turn things back over to our
chairman
thank you very much we will go on into
the next bill uh i would advise those on
the education committee if somebody has
to take a break go do so
you may
go out walk the hall if you have to
but we will then
continue with our legislation that's on
before us this morning the next bill i'd
like to hear is
hb 1564
fn
requiring school districts to provide
breakfast for students
do we have
we have uh do we have um
whose theme
let's see let me get to this
1564.
yeah okay it's got to be a
representative you can fill out the card
afterwards
okay representative you have the floor
uh thank you mr chairman thank you
committee for uh for permitting me to
speak again today i'm gonna be very
brief i know you guys are starting to um
to fall behind on um
on kind of your schedule so in respect
to time um
i have about
i'll go over the the um kind of the
broadest points um
so
the purpose of this legislation is to
provide every student in hampshire the
same opportunity breakfast in the
morning not every student is provided
that same opportunity in every school
district
from a phys from a philosophical point
of view i believe every student deserves
the same opportunity to be able to have
the same educational um
the same educational outcomes and i
think breakfast is an important part of
that and as previously discussed in
previous testimony that i've given
there's a you know myriad of benefits to
our to the students to the educational
system in our society when we do such a
thing um i could read you the facts from
the usda and the school breakfast
program but i'll just submit it to the
clerk to promulgate to you guys at a
later time i have an amendment that i've
drafted for the committee to consider
which would exempt private schools and
only make it so it's required for
for
school boards or publicly chartered
schools it would also provide an am an
exemption for uh for any kind of issue
regarding um
[Music]
supply chain
uh due to copen 19 pandemic so i'll
submit that to the clerk too with my
testimony um
the probably the biggest concern that'll
be brought up is a loss of local control
i think we've kind of discussed that you
know at times government this state
government steps in as a dylan rule
state and decides to create guard rails
for specific expectations to meet the
needs of constituents and specifically
students in this case
the concern of an unfunded mandate may
come up if i'm not mistaken the
legislation does go into effect after
the next budget season
let me double check to make sure that
i'm not misleading the the committee on
that
it does yep correct and so um
new hampshire has historically at times
reimbursed local local districts for
meals or for breakfast if i'm not
mistaken the 2013-14 biennium budget
reimbursed at about three cents per meal
the federal government reimburses at a
much larger rate i did provide in the
legislation a choice for districts to
choose whether or not to serve their own
breakfast which would be determine what
they decided breakfast could be it could
be a bag for you know maybe an apple and
a granola bar or they could opt into the
federal program and get reimbursed for
these meals so trying to preserve an
element of local control but also trying
to make sure that the state is having
our local governments meet the needs of
students and the needs of our of our
constituents and with that i'll remain
open to any questions thank you thank
you very much representative uh
represent likus
never mind
represent porter
thank you mr chair thank you again
representative um you brought up the
um amendment that would
make it not a requirement for private
schools do you know if currently there
are private schools who are part of the
federal lunch program
i think that would be a better question
for the department of education i can
find that out for you though and get
back to representative porter but i i'm
not aware of i've only gone to public
schools my entire life follow-up
so i'm just curious as to why your
amendment would um do away with the
private schools requirement
i think it was an and this is an
amendment i'm also crafting the same
thing for house bill 1561
uh and the purpose being private schools
i think they they we should we shouldn't
have when people choose a private option
they choose that private option to get
away from the government provided option
and i like to keep you know the private
schools and what what what regulations
they have separate from the regulations
that we might place upon public schools
public schools or within our purview i
think i think it's quite clear i think
also regarding you know providing an
adequate education it's pretty explicit
that that
must mean public schools so i just
wanted to keep that separate let the
private schools do what they privately
do and let us handle our government
schools
one last follow-up thank you but now
that we have the voucher program private
schools are getting our state money
so wouldn't we
need to have the same rules for them
seeing as how it's taxpayer money that's
going to the private schools
yeah thank you for the question
representative um i would like to
differentiate with the uh the current
efa program which um you know is quite
new and i think it's gonna be a great
opportunity for many students and uh
families um it's not technically a
voucher program because we're not
providing direct vouchers it's a
scholarship organization that's going to
be helping operate the money and it's
the way where the state is
the state is providing money into
accounts that are run that are operated
and you know presided over by the
scholarship organization to the benefit
of parents that choose to utilize such
program
if it was a direct voucher program we
might be talking about something
slightly different but um
you know the choice of how parents who
opt into this program for their children
how they utilize those dollars i don't
think that because they're utilizing
these dollars to level the playing field
that that then should mean private
schools have to be um you know tied into
every single government school
requirement i think part of the reason
why they're even utilizing the dollars
is because they might have objections
some of the government school
requirements so that's kind of the
reason why i felt as if drawing that
kind of line there of saying the private
schools will you know they'll do their
private school things and there are
people who prefer those private school
things in the government schools will do
those government school things and i
think another impetus for why i've
introduced some of this legislation is
to make our public schools more
competitive with private schools right i
think that's important i think that's
part of the reason why the original
education freedom accounts were
introduced was to provide some level of
competition so that parents can choose
the best education for their child and
for us as a state and for local school
boards to kind of react and say how can
we improve our educational standards
improve the services that we're
providing
further questions represent like us
yes thank you sorry my brain stopped in
the middle as asking this question
you say that
any child who meets the federal income
eligibility guidelines
my question is what about all of those
students who meet that but have their
parents haven't applied for the national
school breakfast program so they're not
i think that's a that's a great question
and thank you for asking it
representative leckis um i think that
would be up to the school district i'm
not mistaken to decide whether or not
they have those students pay the full
price for the breakfast that they're
offering for those students or for the
school district to cover the cost but
that would be at least the way i
interpreted and the way i intended for
the bill to be interpreted um that it
would be a local decision over how much
the school district would be willing to
cover theoretically they can make it so
then the pupil has to cover the full
cost of the breakfast
represent
represent luna we won't have any more
follow-ups i'm just going to try to
catch up a little bit here
thank you thank you very much mr mr
chair and thank you very much
representative uh deschez for bringing
this forward would um
would 1564
apply to
let's say pinkerton academy
which which i believe is one of the
largest providers of public public
education services in the state yeah
i would i would say probably not because
it's a private school if i'm not
mistaken
so i would say it's not a requirement
for pinkerton and i think pinkerton has
decided to stay as a private entity um
for a number of reasons that those
communities have wanted to have it that
way and i think for that reason they've
decided to um you know there's a number
of things where they're not subject to a
number of uh
state federal and even you know other
requirements
so i kind of think it's fair in this
legislation to respect that and for the
amendments and i'm bringing forth for
other bills that have introduced this
committee to respect that decision i'd
like to interject just for a second
please
uh we have pinkerton academy and st
johnsbury academy where kids from new
hampshire go even though cj is over in
vermont they're independent schools
that means they're partially public and
private
and their boards are appointed trustees
so
my position would be yes
because they do receive direct funding
from the state of new hampshire at
pinkerton and the same for
uh st johnsbury academy from the state
of vermont
so they most likely be inclusive within
this as a public public private
independent school okay thank you for
clarifying that mr chairman apologies
further question
okay thank you um
yes representative woodcock
thank you chairman president
two questions very simple
um
i'm assuming this this legislation is
because this is not happening now do you
know how many school assistants in new
hampshire do not offer breakfast
i should have brought that figure in
front of me today it was uh it was um
over the summer when i worked with the
department of education and talked to
them when i was first introducing this
bill in the fall we did discuss that
number um i can get that answer for you
and i can um i can provide it to you by
email after the hearing i apologize for
not having it
just to push that a little farther the
fiscal note does say there are 30
public schools currently not offering a
breakfast program okay thank you mr
chairman one more for me yes thank you
uh does this does this uh bill or will
this bill apply to shadow schools
public charter schools um
under the amendment if the amendment
were adopted that i drafted for the
committee yes because the public charter
yeah counter schools to be
uh regulated by amendments like this
representative have to be identified as
charter schools yep and and so in even
though they're public schools yeah in
the amendment it's explicit each school
board and chartered public school so i i
make it explicit part of conversion
school to what we have in the other
charter schools are public schools in
the state of new hampshire
representative mullen you have thank you
i do thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for bringing this to us
my question was originally in that
fiscal note it says 30 new hampshire
public schools currently not offering a
breakfast program
and i would want uh clarity on whether
or not that's actual public schools or
public school districts because
i i think it could make a
pretty big difference in the number of
schools
and the answer to the question is there
are some public schools that do not
offer
at least prior to covid public schools
that did not offer a meals program they
didn't participate and there were
private schools that did participate so
you might want to uh double check on
that too
when you're talking to them
thank you uh thank you for your question
and i'll certainly do that and i'll try
to follow up with you and represent
woodcock
is department of education hiding back
there is that mckenzie back there
do you have an answer to that so we
might get it right
whether the 30s or 30 are
school districts or
public schools
which would be a huge difference in
well
you can say yes
they're
watch come on up so that we we can um
you don't have to represent the shay
we're not you know you're you're so
ok
thank you appreciate it um so 30 refers
to public schools that are participating
in the national school lunch program but
are not providing school breakfasts so
that does not include the public schools
that are not participating in in nslp
so just clarification is public schools
not school districts that is correct but
that is 30
public schools that are participating in
the federal program that are not
providing breakfast that is not the
universe of public schools to which this
would apply and we're trying to clarify
that data now thank you
does that answer where you came from
representative mullen
it it does i would just ask uh before
you leave mckenzie the um the second
part of my comment was that we have
private schools that actually
participate in the federal foods program
at least that was true prior to covet is
it still true
are there any more questions for
reference desche uh yes represent hobson
thank you for taking my question uh i
just wanted clarification in the bill
uh whoops
on
uh line three you mentioned such meals
shall be served with cost or at a
can you can you explain how that would
i can give you my interpretation
and kind of part of what i kind of
intended and um that's a very good
question
reduce cost i guess that could mean
from a small amount that the uh that the
child has to pay to you know or the
family to a larger amount but i i would
assume then that that would um imply
that
a um
a certain amount of cost has to be borne
by the um by the uh
thank you very much are there further
questions
thank you very much representative thank
you
we have
jessica graham from the
oh that's
sorry it's a small line
yeah
apologize i have old eyes
that's okay
uh good morning chairman ladd and
representatives of the house
education committee my name is jessica
goran i'm the deputy director of new
hampshire hunger solutions our
organization advocates advocates to end
in food insecurity improve access to
nutritious food and address hunger's
root cause issues for all new hampshire
residents
new hampshire hunger solutions is
committed to improving participation in
school meals
with a focus on school breakfast i'm
here today to speak in support
of house bill 1564 requiring all new
hampshire schools to offer school
breakfast
new hampshire ranks 47th
out of 50 states in our nation in school
breakfast participation
each day new hampshire misses serving 7
869 students school breakfast
and annually leaves 1 million 524
771 federal dollars on the table the
research done by the food research and
action center and no kid hungry show
that increased meal participation leads
to healthier students who are able to
learn
this leads to high test scores increased
graduation rates and improve short-term
and long-term economic outcomes
in the short term increased
participation helps to increase revenues
for food service department
departments which often have their own
funding
and revenue streams separate from school
districts
in the long term higher graduation rates
lead to higher rates of
pay post graduation it has also been
proven that students who eat breakfast
at school are less likely to be food
insecure as adults new hampshire has
shown that it cares about access to
school breakfast when it passed senate
bill 82 in 2019 and governor governor
sununu signed it into law as an addendum
to rsa 189 11-a this rsa requires that
all students who are eligible for school
for reduced-priced meals at school
receive a free breakfast and the state
of new hampshire provides the
reimbursement for such meals to school
districts
house bill 1564 will improve where new
hampshire stands on school breakfast
participation leading to a strong new
hampshire workforce and to make sure
all students have access to the
nutrition they need to achieve
educational
success thank you very much are there
questions
not seeing any hands or yes represent
nelson
thank you mr chairman just one the seven
thousand that you mentioned students
what about the parent who prefers the
old days to feed their child at home
before they go is that part of the 7 000
um the part of the 7 000 is a number
that's based on
a ratio that was provided by the food
research and action center so that
number is for every 100 free and reduced
eligible students participating in
school lunch they would like to see 70
free and reduced eligible students
participating in school breakfast
and in new hampshire we have 45.6
free and reduced eligible students that
participate in school breakfast for
for the questions
not seeing any hens thank you very much
and the last pink card i have is nancy
vaughn
yes good morning once again i'm going to
be very brief american heart associate
nancy vaughan with the american heart
association government relations
director we are in support of this bill
because it does offer
children more nutrition
for their health and also prepares them
better for for their school day
and my written testimony does comment on
children from families of low income
that this bill would
would
help
considerably thank you thank you very
much other questions
thank you very much
i i see we have department of education
back there still
i i asked the question whether it be
from mackenzie snow or caitlyn davis i
see you here caitlyn
the question is of the
amount of money provided to these
schools for the breakfast program is
there any money that the local district
has to raise locally in order to pay for
thank you for the question mackenzie
snow division director of learner
support again for the record and kelly
rambo director of onps for the record um
so right now the average meal price for
school breakfast
is two dollars and 35 cents um that
includes
an additional piece of aid the national
average is
2.72 cents so we would estimate that it
so as a follow-up to pay for the program
is the money that comes from the federal
government
by way of this grant
take care of the costs the total cost to
run the program or is there anything
that
if these 30 schools go that direction
are they going to have to put additional
dollars in their budget to make it work
so we we only have a set
reimbursement rate from the federal
government and from the state so if
there are additional expenses that would
be incurred at the local level we would
not track that information necessarily
so that could vary between school
districts and schools
so
and one last follow-up forgive me
committee so if we have x number of
dollars in the pot for the program and
we add 30 schools more into that pot
are the receiving districts right now
going to receive less
no not necessarily that's based on a
set federal reimbursement rate but this
bill as we understand it does require
either participation in the national
school lunch program
and the provision of breakfast and lunch
but if you do if you choose not to
participate in the national school lunch
program there must be a
locally supported
provision of school breakfast so whether
you participate or not the requirement
persists okay
are the further questions of the
department yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh mackenzie so uh
there was a reference made to senate
bill 82 in 2019 that the governor signed
in which it was stated this morning
that new hampshire assumed
responsibility for the costs
of a free breakfast to any student who
qualifies
uh
do you have any sense of how much money
is being spent by the
state at this point or how many schools
are actually taking advantage of that
so again we have um
of our 466 schools participating in slp
all of those participate in breakfast
with the exception of 30. so that is the
is that responsive to your question
okay
represent lake
so if the school is currently not doing
breakfast i.e they're not hiring people
they don't have the cafeteria
working at that point etc
does what the federal government pay per
meal
cover would they cover all of that the
extra help the extra people all of that
kind of stuff is it sufficient
thank you for the question so um
in our
recommendation that the amount would be
indeterminable the cost of the local
level would be indeterminable in that we
include startup costs which it would
include equipment labor onboarding
training of staff outreach about the
opportunity and from other states we
know that estimates could be up to 23
000 per school
depending on what equipment what
infrastructure the school and school
district have currently
and again those startup costs would not
thank you very much um we're going to
close this hearing now uh the
department's here for technical support
they never filled out a pink card but
they're here for technical support
anytime we need that uh other input that
might be coming from the audience right
now please submit a question or
information that you may have to us in
writing and this committee will look at
that thank you very much this hearing is
closed
uh the next bill which we have uh prior
to lunch here is
um
hb one one four two eleven forty two
relative to the right to submit evidence
no no let's see no no no no no i'm i'm
on the wrong i'm in children and family
law
yeah
we don't want to go there do we um h.b
fn establishing an education freedom
account program administrator in the
department of education and making an
appropriation therefore
so with that i'd like to welcome
representative hill uh to speak on the
bill or to present the bill thank you
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
i am uh representative greg hill
i represent the town of northfield and
one third of the city of franklin
i'd like to comment quickly that the
lights are a little dimmer in here
i'm here introducing uh house bill 1627.
um this was legislation requested by the
department
um as we are all aware thus far this new
efa program is tremendously popular with
parents
as with any controversial program the
amount of misinformation about what the
law says or doesn't say is immense
as stated in the legislation the
education freedom account administrator
a new position shall coordinate
and provide technical assistance to
guide students parents and the
scholarship organizations responsible
for dispensing
the education freedom accounts under rsa
194 f the education freedom account
administrator will also serve as a
resource
for administrators educators families
scholarship organizations and policy
makers across the state
i see the department is here um for that
reason i
think i will decline
um to waste any more of your time and
suggest that the questions would be best
served by the department thank you very
much representative hill you never waste
our time
you may take our time up but you don't
okay representative uh
weiler
yes represent porter
is there any more copies of
representative weiler's information yes
short one we sort of split them both
ways i think there'll probably be some
you're welcome
ken would you press the button please
gotcha here it goes representing ken
weiler rocking m13 the townsville
hampstead and kingston
the education freedom accounts have
proven successful for families of
students who are not succeeding in
regular public schools
and this handout fiscal effects of
school choice by martin f luken show the
following recent numbers for new
hampshire
413 students participating at a cost of
2.3 million this represents 0.2 percent
of the students and 0.1 percent of total
schools costs
we see increasing demand for this
program and even at its present level
there will continue to be requests for
guidance enough to justify the hiring of
a full-time administrator the decisions
of this legislature guided by this
committee
is to showing is to allowing education
choice to deliver better results for our
state overall i hope that you will pass
this bill i will pass in this handout if
you don't have it from ed choice
fiscal research and education center
as the some of the figures i referred to
thank you mr chair happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions for our representative
weiler yes representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative weiler for
um for taking my question
as the um as a former chair of the um
the house finance committee uh do you
have any concerns or reservations
regarding a program that was budgeted at
129 000 and so far has clocked in at
over eight million dollars in terms of
i do not as a supporter of this there
are ways within that that uh budget
which is very large to move some monies
around and that's what we do in finance
committee but we try to meet the demand
follow follow up
thank you very much um would you be
moving that money around from within the
education uh trust fund
as much as possible
yes because every year there seems to be
reduction in student count so
that usually is excess money
follow up on that yes
um thank you very much for uh for taking
my question um the in terms of the
reduction on student counts i believe
the education trust fund
is based on um on actual
uh student numbers or student um
adm numbers provided by the department
for the prior for the prior year is that
not the case
yes
thank you however within the current
year there are still
differences
okay uh represent tanner
thank you chairman for for recognizing
me and thank you representative weiler
for taking my question
um
the scholarship organization gets a
sizeable amount of money
uh to administer this program the efas
and since it's grown to eight million
dollars and probably going up even more
i'm wondering if
some of that money
could be used to offset this position at
the department of education
uh that's that's
that's certainly something that we'll be
able to address when we get the bill
over to us
at this point we haven't really got into
that fine
print of that uh detail thank you
further questions
representative woodcock
thank you chairman land rover weil thank
you for uh being here today i just have
one question can you tell me the date of
november 2021
21 so
well over a year ago right you know
within the last year this is not past
november 21. okay thank you
are there further questions
not seeing hans thank you very much
representative weiler i'll leave this
yes i'm here to uh my name is chao kelly
i'm from hooksett new hampshire
and i'm here to support this bill
uh one one two seven
right um
so
six seven one one sixteen twenty seven
uh sixteen twenty seven i'm sorry i
couldn't remember the numbers
um
i um i help a lot of people
to register their kids for this program
and
a lot of them like very disappointed
that the income
prohibits them
from enrolling their kids into these
programs
and they love this freedom account
and even my own family
i try to help my nephew enroll into this
program
and i have many questions
so it would be very helpful
to have
people
and funding designated to help a lot of
parents
and and guidance
to enroll the kids into the programs of
the parents choice
the parents leaving the public school
for many reasons
and one of the main reasons is the
critical race theory and the other thing
is about those things that
the public school
some of them teaching like this sexual
stuff
that even adult don't even they're
talking about
so it's corrupt the child's mind and the
child's innocence at such early age at
any age actually
so i'm here to ask for your support
to support this bill
and if possible
get rid of this income limit
or maybe raise it up to 500 000 or
something like that because 150 000 with
the income and inflation right now it
means nothing
and parents live in the limbo
to like get the children stuck in the
public school
when they go to the school board
meetings the school board
treat them like
enemies they don't even listen to their
parents they make decisions for the
parents to teach what's in the school
which is wrong
parents should have the primary choice
in what their child should learn and
should not learn
so that's why this freedom account is a
freedom for the parents to choose
but why is that we have such a
discrimination based on the income
on the parents
all men are created equal
not rich men and women are different no
we should have that choice
and i'm speaking on behalf of a lot of
new hampshire citizens i went to a lot
of fair and set up tables with my
friends and team
to help people to tell people about
these programs to give them choices
and help them sign them up i got emails
to prove it to you
so please support this bill and get rid
of that income limit or raise it to
500 000 you keep up with it with the
inflation rate that should be it true
thank you so much
this this bill has nothing to do with
income it has to do with an
administrator at the department of
education to manage the program i rest
so many bills today so i'm sorry i'm all
over the places thank you but thank you
are you willing to take any questions
definitely
i don't see any hands up so thank you
very much
thank you for your time
you're welcome
um we have the department of education
here uh are there any technical
questions to ask of the department
or anything that department has to offer
yes so uh
i i don't know if this is mckenzie or
okay
mackenzie you got it
representative who had the hand up
represent like us
thank you mackenzie oh and caitlyn too
yay hello thank you for answering my
questions
um
my understanding i
with this bill i ended up talking with
the scholarship organization
and
it seems that at least for all of the
setup which was the large hard work of
figuring out how all this works and
everything that ended up laying on the
scholarship organization which makes
sense they're the ones that get 10
percent
i'm just wondering now
that
um
[Music]
they're using i guess i4c to put in
pupils and double checking and checking
with schools and making sure that
nothing is
you know the kids aren't multiply
enrolled
and and all of that kind of stuff and
most of the work of setup is done
it seems like
um
now we're shutting the door after the
horse is gone i'm wondering why we need
this position now it seems like it would
have been really good at the
in the last year
so first of all thank you for the
question i completely agree it had been
very helpful to have an administrator at
the beginning of this program
the original fiscal note for the bill
did have a administrator and
unfortunately the legislature chose not
to give us that position at the
department of education
um
i the uh the initial work the initial
set up the program
was very cumbersome from the department
um as are all of the new programs that
are continuously created by the
legislature for the department without
existing or without additional staff so
i would like everybody to remember that
as you're working through the session
the amount of work the department does
but there is a lot of ongoing work
that's
included so
while the scholarship organization is
working directly with the parents no
different than a public school or
non-public school working directly with
parents that are enrolled
there's a lot of reporting and oversight
that needs to be done by the department
of education that is ongoing
work for the department to take on
each year
there are several
large data reports that are done by the
scholarship organization
the children's scholarship foundation
has been
a very good kind of test case and the
number of times you know we had to go
back and forth and we're working very
regularly on sundays to try to work
through data
there are a lot of those that i don't
want to repeat and hopefully having a
full-time administrator will
provide some support for the department
every single time the
scholarship organization enters data to
our system because of the
partially because of the type of systems
that we have or we don't have real-time
data collection systems
we have to
reconcile that all out by hand we have
to work with the scholarship
organization to say you've submitted the
student but the student is submitted by
the school you have conversations with
the school and the scholarship
organization in no different manner than
we do when two public schools submit the
same student so it's just additional
work that's been created with these with
the efa program
other things that come hand in hand are
the legislative oversight committee and
data requests by the legislature by
members of the public
the rfps and the contract negotiations
that come with um doing a scholarship
organization
request for proposal and and then
ongoing operations um
additional reporting requirements that
will likely come on the department so it
is a
an ongoing program that needs support
within the department as well as the
support that the scholarship
organization is providing directly to
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions represent luna
uh thank you very much mr chair and uh
thank you very much for uh for being
with us this morning um representative
weiler referred to
the program as yielding better results
for our state i believe that's what his
exact words were but as far as results
go and i think this ties into um into
your testimony ms davis
um would would this administrator be
able to
provide
provide results obviously not
not connected with specific students but
but but results as far for this program
as far as student performance
local expenditures and statewide
so this position would take up those
responsibilities related to the academic
achievement of those efa participating
students
so state expenditures yes local
expenditures i'm unsure to what you're
referring all right
uh thanks let me be very clear at the um
when when uh when this voucher program
was being proposed the primary um
one of the primary emphasis uh offered
by the commissioner was that there was
going to be substantial reduction in
local
public school expenditures so given that
um you know was was a was a significant
motivation behind the program i think it
would be fair to
ask the department to um to to track and
present the results of those local
expenditures
thank you for the clarification yes this
would be included the impact on local
school districts and enrollments would
be included in the responsibilities of
the administrator
thank you very much
representative ellison
thank you mr chairman thanks for being
here thanks for taking my question uh
clarification does the department have
open positions for school coordinator or
school counselors and school nurses to
your to your
college
so we do not employ school counselors we
have a team within the division of
learner support
the office of social and emotional
wellness which has
mtssb consultants covering our five
regions
two of those positions are open
and then related to school nurses that
is a position that has been open for
follow-up yes
do you have any sense about when these
are going to be filled because i think
the school nursing position has been
open for quite a while we are we have a
number of positions open across the
agency we are no exception to the
constraints on on hiring and the
attractiveness of state employment um so
we are actively recruiting for a number
of positions across the agency
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you ladies
i believe what representative ellison
was referring to was a position that was
created in 2019
for a director of school counseling that
was going to fall under the bureau of
student support has that
position
been eliminated or
i know it hasn't been filled because
there's no person in that job but
what has happened to that position
so we have a number of positions that
work directly with school counselors
it's not directly relevant to this bill
but i'm happy to follow up on a
historical position about what you're
asking
represent
tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question will you be working
with the giving and going alliance also
for the christian academies
so the giving and going alliance did
tell us that they did not want to
participate this time around when we did
our first contract this summer however
we will be releasing an rfp shortly at
the department and any organization that
is registered under 77 g
is more than willing or more than able
to apply for the for the
contract
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you ladies
for taking my question
in the
version of the freedom account bill that
passed in the budget
it said that the
scholarship granting organization would
be able to decide
which programs
for coverage under this program
would this position
be able to do that instead of the
organization i mean would they be making
decisions
about which program
should could be funded with these
so under current statute we do review
the application process for education
service providers and that
responsibility would be a part of this
position but again the scholarship
organization directly receives those
in
applications and reviews the education
service providers who
are
follow-up is are there guidelines that
the department will be offering to the
scholarship granting organization to
help them make those decisions
for example
um how does the organization or the
department decide which um religious
school would be funded
i mean what which schools of which
religion would be funded
so
determinations uh upon eligib um
different determinations of eligibility
on the basis of religion would be um
likely unconstitutional um so i'm not
sure that that would be a relevant
criteria in the the religious nature or
the the specific
religion associated with an education
service provider
but for
those
criterion related to the provision of a
high quality education to a student
an administrator could certainly advise
thank you are there any further
representation thank you
thank you for being here
um
am i
correct in that this is not a voucher
program and that a voucher is not given
to a family to go to a particular school
but in effect is an education savings
account
program and there are
a list in the legislation of valid
expenses for which
a parent
could pay for
educational options for their
child that's correct there's a multitude
of education expenses and potential
types of education service providers
including institutions of higher
education
tutors special education service
providers and therapists so thank you
for the clarification
it would not be limited to
oversight or advisement of non-public
school education service providers thank
you i'd like to at this time thank the
department for offering us technical
support and advice here
at this point in time i'm going to close
yeah at this point in time we are
breaking for lunch and we'll convene at
you
yeah
okay it's uh one o'clock and i'd like to
go ahead with the the uh agenda for this
afternoon
before we get into the specifics of
these bills 1630 right down to 11 44
uh
the way this agenda for the afternoon is
put together
we have a number of bills are dealing
with various aspects of curriculum
be it pe be it labor history be it uh
philosophy
uh all civics
i know that there are some folks who may
be testifying on various bills some
maybe on all bills
and there may be a common thought
through all those bills seeing we're
dealing with curriculum
and
i've suggested to one individual that
came up here during lunch break
if you are testifying on all these bills
but there's a common thread you can
mention that at the beginning of the
first bill here
and you can sign the blue sheets
and and indicate your position on on
each bill on those blue sheets and
submit written testimony
but rather than reproducing or saying
over and over and over again
this one position
you don't have to do that we understand
it sorry so that way we may be able to
get through this in a way that without
you know hearing the same thing over and
over and in a timely manner of course we
are bound by a
schedule that's here but uh
that would i think that would help it
might even help those who are here that
would like to get out
and get on with other affairs that
they're dealing with so
so that that advice is given right now
to all who might be willing wanting to
testify on this bill
the first bill
being a bill 1630 with representative
saudi as the representative and he is
not here today so i will be introducing
that bill for him
and as soon as i get over there then
representative cordelli is going to take
so we will open the hearing on house
bill
requiring high school students to
complete a half year required course in
the introduction to philosophy
and i will call upon
chairman ladd
to
open
this
bill and introduce it for us
thank you very much mr chair and members
of the education committee for the
record
my name is rick ladd i'm a
representative from haverhill new
hampshire
i'm here today to uh introduce hb 1630
which is a bill that's already been
defined by the chair uh dealing with uh
the area philosophy in the in the high
school level
i'm doing this on behalf of
representatives sati who's not able to
be here today
i am not a co-sponsor or our sponsor of
this bill but i feel that it's important
that this bill be introduced and that
there be some discussion on it
i have before me uh the representatives
written testimony i would like to read
that
uh into the record for
uh by it's written by mr saudi
representative saudi and
it's it is as follows as the primary
sponsor of hb 1630
i am submitting my testimony in writing
due to illness
and out of an abundance of caution
this bill looks to require introduction
to philosophy the level of wisdom to be
taught as a half year course in high
school
i'm not one to go
dictating and micromanaging what should
be taught in our schools especially in a
world exponentially increasing
information
but there are some core essentials
one must be wise choose wisely
what the essential foundational tools
are and let people pursue their areas of
interest as they see fit
first let me be clear
up clear clear up what i mean by
philosophy i do not mean philosophy as a
form of ideology but as a means of
inquiry
this is not about teaching students what
to think but about how to think
question and inquire to understand that
there is an anatomy to acknowledge and
degrees of certainty to understand the
age-old philosophical question how do
you know that you know
this is why the bill specifies the areas
of philosophy
that should be covered theory of
knowledge
logic ethics and the philosophy of
science
in the past year we had a bill that
touched on some of these issues
i chose to make a broader approach this
with this bill
philosophy is the traditional path to
law school
a ph doctorate in philosophy is the
highest degree awarded to many of our
academics
the lessons of philosophy
philosophy create a thinking citizenry
one who makes wise choices
we owe our high school students in
education and philosophy
it is our intellectual heritage
it is our legacy
please join me in supporting this bill
let us not yet again posthumously
condemn socrates to death
thank you for your consideration
represent julius saty
windham
i have just a few remarks and i will
give those remarks um
from ricklad haverhill in new hampshire
uh as you know i was a
school principal and a fourth year four
or fourth grade teacher for many many
many years
uh
number three
school not a number of years is an
elementary principal in elementary
schools
and curriculum is uh an area that i love
and i feel this part of that core of
what we do along with instruction and
alignment of assessment and school
facilities to make our education safe
productive and a learning experience
as a as a
elementary school principal
i wrote a number of curriculum
throughout the state one of the
curriculum was developed and written in
the state of maine it's now owned by
downeast magazine it dealt with the
social studies but though when i was up
in alaska
as the school principal there
one of the areas that we very much got
involved with in teaching how to think
came from a program called great books
foundation the junior great books
right here some of you may be familiar
as educators what this disk did
it's a a system of shared inquiry
you read the story once you get the
facts you read it again you have a lot
of discussion amongst people in the
classroom and you get into different
types of questioning
questioning for facts questioning for
interpretation
questioning for evaluation what do you
think about the story what was the
author trying to convey to us you'll
find that there's many many cases not a
correct answer
there's many answers that can make
things correct and many different ways
of perceiving and seeing
teaching the best ways to think on your
own is what this program is all about
it's how to think
and we did this starting in the younger
grades by then i'm saying write down in
first grade right in kindergarten all
the way up through junior high school
the school the grades i had in that
particular building
and what we did we learned that
the philosophy of of learning how you
learn
the logic and the rhetoric that's
necessary are key components to how we
learn
so
i feel that from my perspective
we can't just start this at one grade
level in high school and have a
philosophy course say there you've got
it it's a way of thinking it's aware of
shared learning and shared understanding
and shared in inquiry
which is important too many times you
read a book
and you always go into next next section
see what happens
and and seeing that basic concrete
sequential type information the facts
but then we have to sort through the
facts and find out why is it being
written how does it relate to me how
does it relate to you with my other
classmates that's the discussion that
gets you to the higher order thinking
skills this is why when we had hb 242
before us in the previous year
we note that in that bill we talked
about logic and rhetoric
key
components to learning key components
learning the core foundational elements
that are part of
education
and
we saw it then and we need to see it now
that anything we do we're going to have
to be looking at those components logic
how you think and
rhetoric how we communicate
so with that i will
stop my testimony i'll take questions
from my perspective but i can't take
questions for representative saudi
thank you are there any questions
from the committee representative lakas
since we're going to be dealing with a
lot of bills that have to do with
curriculum
can you explain
now as we're getting started basically
what our role in curriculum is what the
does role is and what the town's role is
so we understand when we're looking at
these
within curriculum
we have various targeting targeted
learning expectations
for our students which are learning
those are called competencies
curriculum and instruction curriculum is
the material the outline of where we are
what's in the course what's in a program
and the instructional component the
methodology how we teach
is that of the instruction in that
school or in that district it's a
methodology you can go from one
classroom to another and you're going to
see different ways of communicating
doesn't say one's right one's wrong
it means there's different ways of
structuring and organizing organizing
your your
imparting the areas of curriculum which
we have to teach instruction is
curriculum instruction two different
things
and we do have our standards which
associate with what we want as what are
those academic standards that all should
achieve to be competent and the
curriculum is the material we use to
get into it have those objectives which
we're trying to learn
identified and and uh how we teach so
with instructions so i hope i can it's
hard to answer that question in one
brief sentence or two i hope that helps
you a little bit
thank you you're welcome thank you uh
representative moffitt thank you mr
thank you russian vlad for taking my
question you'll recall that last term we
had uh at hb 242 with regard to an
adequate education which you spent a lot
of time on which passed the house in the
senate but the governor vetoed it so i'm
just wondering
how how do you do you see this
philosophy
course potential requirement or how do
you see philosophy tying into an
adequate education or do you see i
worked you used the word course
and
the there's a lot of courses which we
teach in fact if you look at your rules
that have in 306 education 306 the uh
in order to have a
a public school that's approved in all
we have these rules which identify the
elective courses the primary courses you
have to have in order to have those 20
credits to graduate from high school
the
how you think
in my perspective is embedded in
if you're going to go the route of
philosophy as a separate required course
are we adding something on top of what
we already have and there's going to be
some other issues associated with that
there's going to be costs
there's going to be certification
requirements who's going to teach that
course um
i don't know if i'm necessarily agreeing
with that i didn't come here to you know
take a position on it right now i want
to hear
this committee discuss it a little bit
however i'm uh
believe that you can teach everything i
talked about in the junior great books
here
in this foundation this program whether
you're doing it civics are you doing it
in literature whether you're doing it
and you're thinking on some other
subject core area within your your
school
we oftentimes will teach social studies
via literature
and in the literature class
some schools may not do it they may have
a straight textbook to do that it's
really a local issue and how it's going
to be conveyed in that school
years ago we had some schools that had
all the walls in the classroom some had
no walls in the classroom some used
inquiry science some did not use it you
can go down the list
and and so it's that's a local decision
your school board has to make that
decision and working with the
instructors in that school
thank you
thank you president porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative ladd i agree with you
that um that is excellence in teaching
and i agree with you and i want to point
out that that kind of excellence in
teaching is going on in classrooms and
public schools all over the state i know
for a fact because i've been in them and
i've watched it happen from little kids
how would
that method of teaching
conflict with the
restrictions that have currently been
put into law about which topics
can be discussed in this way
i am hearing
many people
coming to me saying that they're finding
themselves as teachers
chilled or nervous about doing that kind
of activity with their classes
because of the recent um senate house
bill sb2 that i was built to that put in
the banned concepts language is that a
question about this yeah i'm asking how
he would in his opinion get around
that restriction that teachers have now
to continue to do the kind of deep
inquiry and questioning of values back
and forth between each other that you so
highly praised in the junior great books
thank you very much representative
porter
i don't believe
what i've just spoken about is a
restriction how you teach
i think this this um
methodology
should be applied to everything we do
i i've seen classrooms where i i see
children thriving and enjoying and
respecting each other's opinion
i think it's up to the teacher to be the
guide
and to
and that takes a lot of training to know
how to teach like this this is something
you just don't graph off the shelves and
start this is where in service is very
necessary i don't believe that what's
going on today's society should have any
effect and i don't think the bill that
you're trying to speak to is the
discrimination bill
i don't think that bill has any
restrictions as far as what is taught i
think it means you're not going to
advocate yourself
and push something uh to the kids and
not be respectful of differing positions
this whole concept of the junior great
book program or inquiry uh
shared inquiry is one where we respect
the opinions of others within that
classroom and and uh that's how things
grow i don't think it's going to be a
restrictive i don't think that
what i'm advocating can be done
irregardless it should be how we're
doing things and have been doing things
for years
uh representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative vlad for taking my uh
question
first of all as somebody who taught
junior great books for a
significant number of years and more
recently than you
i
i just want to say how impressed i am
that you could put your hands on your
junior great books manual uh to bring it
in here as exhibit a today and my
question
is um
because i agree with you that uh the
process by which kids learn how to think
is critically important
i'm wondering if you uh
would agree that starting in high school
is a bit late i wonder whether or not
this type of inquiry should in fact be
started earlier in a child's education
than as a standalone high school course
i absolutely agree that
this methodology of instruction shared
inquiry
and learning how to read you read it
once you read it again a second time
that's part of the program
and from that you discern fact you
usually get that the first round
then you get into interpretation and
evaluation this should be done
in the schools i had we started this
program formally in third grade
and we continued on through by the time
i would walk into a classroom in sixth
grade or one of my eighth grade
classrooms
the level of thinking
was just wonderful we initially adopted
this program for our gifted program we
had a gifted program in the school a
gifted teacher in that state gifted was
funded totally
and we had criteria for getting in that
program the gifted teacher then
teacher gifted not
and i would say she was very gifted
but
then turned around and cooperatively and
collaboratively we trained all teachers
on that staff to get into the same venue
which we did and with that we saw a
level of support within the community
the kids went on to do wonderful things
so to answer your question
yes it's important that this process
begin in the elementary grades
and i fear right now that we have kids
that are in third grade now
and when covet started they're probably
kindergarteners
and since that time grades one two and
now three
they've gone through everything that's a
result of covid
some of them not in school much some in
school would you know the mass that i
have around my neck here i should be
wearing but there's a loss there's a
loss in academics and we all know that
my primary goal is that and see what
have they missed they missed the
development of all this
so
i would say that yes we can't lose sight
the elementary schools
everything you know need to know is
learned in kindergarten but beyond that
you all know that
in the lower elementary grades extremely
important especially i i enjoyed
watching those fourth graders
that's where you start seeing them
going from that concrete organization
into that
this logic and that so it's a fun time
for kids we need to start not just as
high school half year course or that
this needs to be
ongoing just like we teach kids how to
use the computers now and we don't wait
thank you any further questions
oh sorry yes represent luna no thank
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative ladd
for introducing the bill and sharing
your um your experience connected to to
this um
just a a couple of more
more i guess process
related related questions but um
will um
would this bill increase the number of
graduation credits
that
that some that some students will need
to achieve in order to
to graduate high school in new hampshire
i was hoping we would discuss that when
we get into a committee uh look at this
as i said i'm not really
um i'm here to just give my own
perspective and understanding i
understand what represents saudi's doing
he believes very much in philosophy as i
do um however is this going to be an
elective course it's going to be a shall
everybody takes part in this course
um
and if so there's going to be an expense
to it right and then and then um just a
a second part on this
on line seven is the effective date 60
days after passage um my from from your
last answer i'm gathering that that this
committee may do a deeper dive into
i'm sure representative mullen if she in
knowing that she's been involved with
this you don't just do it in 60 days
right
this is a type of thing where
you're going to get every you got to get
you got to get a good hold on it you got
to go through doing it yourself you got
to have all the in service and the
preparation for it um we sent teachers
where i was in alaska down to the states
for further training by that i mean out
down to the lower 48.
and um so uh it would take
i would say to get this done properly
you'd have to gradually get it built
through because you know you can't just
start popping this series seven
on a a on a student that and and some of
the things you're looking at within
those guides in the han for the teacher
in the sixth grade without any previous
understandings where you've got to build
towards this
and so it's a way of thinking it's a
thinking which is absolutely we need
more of in our society and we've got to
be respecting those opinions
that this espouses
from different opinions thank you
thank you any further questions seeing
none uh thank you thank you very much mr
chair
next call
jason
soren
is that
thank you mr chairman i'm jason sorens
from amherst new hampshire
and um i am supporting this bill it may
need some amendment as as
we talked about in the
in the discussion just now to give
schools a little more time to prepare
and possibly a little more flexibility
to meet the requirement
but i do support the notion of requiring
a philosophy credit for graduation for
high school students in this state
and the reason for this it's really
twofold first of all
philosophy is relevant to whatever you
do
i am a political scientist by training
but i use philosophy regularly and it
and there is a philosophy of whatever it
is you do
the philosophy can tell you
um for instance if you're a scientist
what is the meaning and significance of
the work that you're doing what is its
value that is what is its end or purpose
those are critical things for us to know
and to be reflective about
the kind of work we do and
i i use philosophy very regularly in my
work
the second reason
why
this requirement would be beneficial is
that
as citizens
we need access to some of these tools to
solve some of the problems that we're
having in our society in our politics
one of the biggest problems i think
everyone has noticed in our politics
nowadays is an increase in tribalism and
confirmation bias that is the the
unwillingness to consider evidence that
challenges your own views and we see
this on on all sides of the political
spectrum
and
philosophy instruction can help us get
away from that by learning logic
epistemology which is the theory of
knowledge
we
see that to to get at the truth
we need to be curious but we also need
to be dispassionate
we need to not think of truth as an
exercise in supporting our team whatever
that may be
but in actually challenging
our team and challenging our
preconceived notions and
noticing recognizing logical fallacies
and avoiding them in our reasoning
process
ideally
introducing students to logic
to
logical fallacies teaching them how to
avoid them teaching them the
the means of getting at truth and the
significance of truth is going to help
them become better citizens
more reflective
more idiosyncratic if you will less
willing to to toe a particular line but
more willing to think for themselves
very few
high school students ever encounter
philosophy before getting to college
and therefore very few college students
and i've taught that the collegiate
level for nearly two decades
very few college students ever even
consider taking a philosophy course
because they've never been introduced to
it these are the biggest
you questions
what is truth what is uh
just in our society
do human beings have free will do we
have moral responsibility these sorts of
questions are the questions that
philosophy investigates they're
questions relevant to all of us and yet
very very few of us ever get to
investigate them in a systematic manner
because we're just not introduced to
these ideas at any point in our academic
careers so new hampshire could certainly
take the lead here
by
encouraging and even ultimately
requiring schools to
offer this course and to to require
their students to take a course in
philosophy perhaps we should
allow extended learning opportunities to
count perhaps it should make clear that
a literature course or a civics course
could also so long as it incorporates
these elements fulfill the requirement
those are possible amendments
that would make this a
less of a burden on schools
but the idea is that students should be
introduced to philosophy before they get
to college
and this bill would accomplish that
thank you
thank you for your testimony
to us any
questions representative moffat
famous chair thank you to my question
very interesting
but you just said that this should be
good for students to be exposed to or to
have washed over them before they go to
college
and when you said that you
that it was a thought that i had
having taught in high schools
and i want to say this delicately
uh i'm picturing a lot of
my high school students
is just not having any interest
whatsoever in epistemology and that type
of thing
in some of the various
school
you know schools of thought amongst
philosophers
i agree with what you said about being
good for
uh
college track students so that said in
the in the
the prime sponsor is not here if isn't
do you see his intent as being this
as a universal requirement or you just
said
for college-bound students what what do
you think about that yeah well i've
talked to representative saudi about
this bill a little bit
and
his his intention is that all high
school students go through this class to
see if this is something that does in
fact interest them and it would be
difficult to somehow limit this course
to
to simply college-bound students how do
you identify those students right how do
we make this a requirement simply for
those students could you try to get out
of the requirement by claiming you're
i will say that what is distinctive and
interesting about philosophy and why i
um enjoy teaching what i get a chance to
my my work is mainly in in political
science as i've said but i have taught
political philosophy
is that everyone has some philosophical
views we're human beings we can't help
but have some philosophic philosophical
views are there objective truths for
instance people have opinions about that
and the method of philosophy the the
thought experiment is the main method
whereby philosophy tries to get at the
truth it's it's
really reflecting on examples or um
sort of situations um like the famous
trolley example in ethics
uh that gets you to
um think about your premises and
uh think about which sorts of premises
are plausible that is a work that my
students really enjoy doing and everyone
can do that right everyone can sit and
think if i were in that situation what
would i think is the right thing to do
it may be more difficult for students
for instance to
um to do biology than to do philosophy
with biology you've got to have some
facility with math you've got to
understand something about the
scientific method and those are all
valuable things
but i think philosophy is actually in
some ways less challenging if
appropriately taught at the high school
level less challenging than for instance
the natural sciences because it
presupposes a little bit less in terms
of technical skills
thank you very much
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much dr sorens for uh for
joining us this afternoon i was
wondering if you could are hoping you
could uh
um comment on um you know what you just
talked about particularly
the invest you know the ability for
students to investigate and explore i
think i wrote down your words correctly
evidence that challenges their own views
and sort of you know crosswalk that or
in juxtaposition
with um
with statutes we have here in new
hampshire that actually ban the
exploration of certain concepts
yeah i've i've obviously followed the
debate over that legislation um to be
perfectly honest i'm not sure what i
think about that legislation personally
i've heard both proponents and opponents
describe it differently
and if the legislation is the way the
opponents describe it i would oppose it
at the legislation the way the
proponents describe it i would support
it we'll have to see how that gets
interpreted
certainly i do not think that that
legislation should be interpreted at any
rate um
to prohibit the discussion of any
concepts and if it does i think that
would that is a problem with that
legislation
that's all
i feel qualified to say about that well
that's fine thank you very much sure
any further questions from the committee
see none thank you very much for being
here
uh next um and i think finally is jerry
frew
thank you mr chairman i feel surrounded
my name is jerry frew
and i am the associate executive
director for the new hampshire school
administrators association
and out of respect for the time demands
on this committee i'm going to offer
testimony in writing
i've provided it to
legislative services and it will
cover a number of curriculum related
bills so i'll speak only once that will
be now and
as a matter of record for the committee
our concerns will be
in the record so that you have that to
look at
part of my role in my current position
and actually part of my past life was
working with curriculum
today i currently work with curriculum
directors and
instructors
assistant superintendents and and the
likes through professional development
and in pretty regular contact with those
folks
i'd just like to ask a question of this
committee if i may
how many of you have ever
been driving or ridden in a vehicle
where that gas tank needle
has come perilously close to empty
and you've wondered if you're going to
reach your destination
and what the stress level and
just kind of that visceral
effect that you have
in your body like oh my are we going to
i'm just going to fast forward that
to the feeling right now of curriculum
folks
and teachers in our classrooms
and administrators in our buildings and
school boards that have to make a lot of
decisions
and tell you
that in my weekly
and sometimes daily communication with
those folks
the tank
is darn near close to empty
and i just would like you to ponder that
thought as you think about
all of these
very well intended
pieces of curriculum legislation
we appreciate the bill sponsors nhsaa
appreciates each bill sponsor's concerns
the passion the interest behind each
proposal
by making this curriculum-related
proposal each sponsor has created an
awareness of the desire of many of our
legislators to see changes in curriculum
offerings and practices
we encourage bill sponsors
with their local
districts and constituents to make these
changes
a one-size-fits-all approach is not
effective in a state where the burden of
funding these changes takes place at the
local level
as the chair of this committee has said
on more than one occasion
curriculum decisions should be made at
the local level
curriculum changes typically are part of
a long-term plan to account for
budgetary implications the distribution
of human resources for professional
training
curriculum staff hiring staff
development
these curriculum-related bills are all
well intended but carry with them
commitments of time
human and sometimes physical resources
that impact our local district's
capacities in one form or another
districts have various capacities to
meet those ambitious timelines for
implementation with each one of these
bills intended to be in place for the
22-23 school year or sooner
by the time the legislative process is
complete course selections class
schedules for students and school
budgets will already have been acted by
local legislative bodies for the
22-23 school year
we encourage each sponsor or legislator
interested in changing the curriculum to
work with their local school systems
officials and communities to achieve
those changes
the very least we'll propose that any
curriculum bill enacted be respectful of
local capacity by allowing phased in or
flexible timelines or implementation
with none of it taking effect until july
2024 at the earliest and be accompanied
by a fiscal note to adequately implement
the legislation
this flexibility allows for local
communities to plan for the fiscal
impact of training
hiring staff facility management and
policy making required as a result of
these decisions
the sheer volume of these bills imposes
demands on local resources and bandwidth
and with all due respect
we ask this committee to look at these
not only as individual bills but in sum
total of all of these proposals as they
impact local curriculum development
it is with that thought in mind that we
asked the committee to find each of
these curriculum bills in expedient to
legislate at this time
or at least retain them for further
study looking at the complete curriculum
package as proposed by the legislature
and we would be very happy to assist
with that process
but when you look at the cte bills the
health wellness physical education
philosophy
the nutrition half hour for lunch there
are lots of things that impact a
school's day time and quite honestly the
human condition
right now
and or next summer nobody's going to
attack the curriculum issues now or even
in the fall it's going to be next summer
sometime
our administrators our teachers our
school folks all need to come up for air
that didn't happen this past summer they
thought they might get a little just a
little swig of that air and then bang
they came back to school in september
and the tsunami came again and so we've
got another year of underwater
and so i ask
in compassion it's funny one of the
pieces that that we've talked about one
of the pieces that the curriculum
directors have talked about is the
frustration that they're experiencing in
getting staff members to even
participate in professional development
like self-care and compassion fatigue
they don't even have the wherewithal to
be able to do those things and we're
asking them now to spend time in the
summer
to revamp curriculum
to
to make
hire more staff
i think i think you've received that
message and
this testimony really satisfies
testimony for about eight bills
so the gift of time is yours and i'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you
any questions
from the committee of representative
lakers
if there are things that we would
obviously there's a whole lot of things
here that various of us want to see in
what would be a way of doing that
that would not
negatively impact the schools
could we you know just say make sure
that in
while you're teaching that you cover
these things i don't know what what do
what suggestions do you have for us
thank you for that question
representative like us and that is a
great question
another part of my job is to make sure
that they're aware of these pieces of
legislation and so we explain the fact
that these are conversations in concord
that they need to look at i believe the
other part is though also we have a
department of education that has a
bureau of student health and wellness
i believe that some of the health and
wellness bills and some of those things
it's as simple as looking at local
curriculum and seeing if those things
are already covered i'm not quite sure
that some of these proposals aren't
already covered in local
presentations i think sometimes at this
level we have a tendency to hear from
one or two outliers that are
dissatisfied with the local situation
and when we dig down and take a look at
it we might find that many of these
uh competencies many of these practices
are already in place and i think that's
the advantage if you will representative
of of referring at least for further
study because i think some of these
things are already addressed i do agree
with
representative luno's question that uh
as the current philosophy bill is
written it would add a requirement for
graduation i i think it was
representative i'm not quite sure but i
believe the way it's written it's a
required
course for graduation from high school i
think anytime something is required it
adds another layer it impedes that kid
that's trying to get into the cte
program because they've got one more
local requirement or one more state
requirement that they have to meet
thank you very much thank you any
further questions
uh scene none thank you thank you and i
will close the hearing on house bill
1630.
yes
okay we're finished the first bill for
this afternoon and we will be now
entering into um
hearing uh hb 1263 presented
by jerry kanerk and i would like to say
to jerry
your penmanship is excellent
i think i printed it i don't know if
that was the palmer method or zayn or
blowser but i can read it i think i use
black caps because as i said my worst
created all of school was penmanship my
okay uh
i spoke with you uh representative
on the horn
um
perhaps when you introduce yourself
you can also explain
what's going on to the rest of the crew
yes sir so welcome to our committee
today this is education we are here to
uh hear the bill hb 1263 introduced
relative to fiscal education in schools
welcome
thank you very much mr chair for the
record my name is jerry kanerk
representative carroll county
representing carroll county district 3
and i'm also a retired orthopedic
surgeon
um i was going to say this to the end
but i will say it at this point
the person who motivated me to file this
bill is a fellow orthopedic surgeon and
sports medicine specialist and educator
dr dan o'neill who truly wrote the book
on this topic titled survival of the fit
he's here to testify today they're also
doing a documentary about it and that is
the reason why we have the person doing
the filming nothing nefarious just
getting ready for a documentary
so basically 1263 sets a minimum
requirement for time spent in physical
education for pupils in school
bottom line our kids are not active
enough they fail to meet even minimum
standards for fitness and this lack of
physical activity is far-reaching with
30 percent of our new england new
hampshire children i should say being
overweight uh 20 oh by the way just in
case you know i did distribute this
earlier so you had the testimony uh 20
meeting the criteria for obesity and we
have elevated rates of type 2 obesity or
sorry diabetes in children
this is probably the first generation in
history is expected to have a shorter
life span than their parents because of
these kinds of chronic illnesses
lack of fitness contributes also to
depression
stress and anxiety and really also it
decreases school performance
you gotta remember children are really
born as very active beings they have a
really strong physical identity and as
the grandfather of a one-year-old boy at
this point i've been really reintroduced
to the incredible level of activity and
exploration of young children but our
current lifestyle allows children to
spend their lives barely moving as they
spend time in front of screens rather
than going outside to either play or do
chores milk the cows and so on and so
forth
now we can address this problem by
ensuring kids get at least a minimum
level of physical activity every day to
help preserve that physical activity
that physical identity
by introducing them to numerous physical
activity choices especially outdoor
individual outdoor activities not just
team sports we can provide a foundation
for an active lifestyle for the rest of
their lives
the cdc notes that physical education in
the school improves grades and test
scores and the ability to stay on task
in the classroom
and that the increased time spent on
physical education does not negatively
affect the student's academic
achievement
the choice of 30 minutes per day for
elementary school students and 45
minutes per day for middle and high
school students
is based upon the institute's institutes
of medicine 2013 report called
evaluating the student body taking
physio physical activity and physical
education to school that laid out the
scientific basis for the recommendations
for physical education in schools
this bill
does not
offer an exemption for team sports as
children should be exposed to numerous
individual life activities and some
sports may not give much activity such
as let's say you're on the baseball team
you're playing right field you're not
even a starter you may not get that much
activity day to day as you're doing that
sport
organized sports are not sufficient as
not everyone participates and children
often segregate themselves into either
athletes or non-athletes far too early
i'm part an example i never did any
sports at all but for my age group i'm
probably one of the more active people
you know with cross-country skiing and
downhill skiing and hiking and biking
and swimming and running i do that stuff
all the day i can't get through a day
without something that's outside i
preserve my physical activity partly
because my folks just sent me outside to
play until the lights until the street
lights came out
in any case i'll be glad to take any
questions if you have them but again
the person who wrote the book is sitting
behind me and he'll be testifying thank
you very much representative are there
yes representative boehm
chairman thank you for taking the
question
um
over the years we've done
a lot of
deep bill a couple of times if i
remember
the problem is as brought up and earlier
that not enough time in the school day
to do this now when i went to high
school we'd had phys ed every day but
the federal government and the state
kept adding stuff and it was on
department my question is on
alternative education which we passed
some years ago
and i know in our high school we did it
with
depending on the number of
what sport you were in
that served as a half credit
for example if you won the football team
you only had to do one year if you have
varsity only basketball varsity only
my granddaughter did gymnastics for four
years that was her alternative credit
that's plenty of exercise so i think
just leaving out the sports is wrong
because there are some sports where no
matter what position you play you're
going to get a lot of exercise and you
agree
yes actually i have to say
um
you know in our health human services
elderly affairs we do a big job of you
know tweaking bills
you have the expertise in education that
i do not have i would expect that
together you will come up with something
that would be far better than what i
submitted thank you
are there further questions from the
committee
yes representative nelson uh thank you
mr chairman thank you for taking my
question representative line six of the
bill
if you have it in front of you yes and
the word or at the end of the sentence i
don't know
and the middle school or high school
engages in a course of physical
education for a minute 220 minimum 225
minutes that means you get your choice
middle or high school
that's how i interpret it so i'm sorry
if i'm wrong
that is not what was intended it would
be minimum 150 weeks for the elementary
school and middle school or high school
engages but it certainly could be
changed and if that is confusing to
people
well i may be the only one
[Laughter]
well if one is confused then it's
confusing
are there further questions from the
committee here
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you very much i appreciate your
time
okay now
we
okay
thank you mr chair for the books i'm
representative linda tanner i represent
sullivan county
district nine which has eight towns
plainfield cornish croydon newport
grantham sunapee springfield
and unity
and i
taught physical education for 35 years
health and physical education at
kearsarge regional high school
i'm here to
to testify today partly to amplify
a testimony that you have from kathy
robgen
who is a former colleague of mine and
she was unable to attend today
but she was an elementary teacher for
several decades at kearsarge as well
and she became the elementary school
teacher of the year in 2008. she's she's
a exceptional person
and
kathy when she was taking her master's
degree
did a little uh study at bradford
elementary school with the fifth grade
um
she's always been a person and i think
trained physical education people are
trained to incorporate curriculum in
their curriculum
academics there's always it's not just
here's the ball go and have a good time
with it
we do a lot with safety we do a lot with
fitness we do a lot with
coordinating things with academics and
kathy did this study with math and you
know sitting on this committee i've
heard about
poor math scores and the reading scores
at grade level three
and so she attacked it by
having a controlled group and a
a group that didn't do anything except
go to math class
and then the other group she worked with
where she paired math
questions and math skills with what was
happening in physical education
and at the end of her period of time she
found out that they then tested them on
the normal tests and
the group that she worked with came out
statistically
higher in math than the group that
didn't and in fact she said one of the
like aha moments the eisen einstein
moment was when this kid said
i finally figured out what perimeter
means
okay so uh kathy kathy did a lot of work
and
she wants you to know that um
and i want you to know as well
that physical education is critically
important physical activity is pretty
critically important in the development
of children
play is how kids learn
and recess
an unorganized play is great but it
isn't
it needs to be at some level organized
and it should be under the tutelage of a
teacher who's been trained in physical
education
and
so
i knew from college that
different studies have proven right
along
that reading is really can be improved
tremendously through physical activity
so i taught at the high school and
one of the things at the high school we
had a required course
in it was called fit for life and it was
really important
i think
and i've had some
some feedback from former graduates how
important it was in their life
that we studied um
and we did you know weight training we
did uh stretching we did yoga we exposed
them to a lot of different activities
but as we were doing them we were
talking to them about how
it improved their immune system which
somebody was here talking about before
we we hit nutrition
we hit a lot of different areas and it
was a course that i feel i was very
proud of that we had that and then on
the other hand
for the rest of their credit they took a
an elective
either in an individual sport or they
could take a team sport but we tried to
really push the individual lifetime
sports because as dr konerk said
you know a lot of people aren't into
basketball and football
and the team sports although i think
they're really important for a lot of
kids as far as building team and being
able to work with other people there's
advantages to team sports
but once you get in your 20s and 30s and
40s and 50s and like i am
way up above that you know i'm still
playing tennis and um i'm not a serena
williams by any means but i play tennis
and um it's really important to be
active
and it gives you a longer lifetime
so i think this is this is a really
important bill i'd also like to remind
people on this committee that have been
on the committee for a while that a few
years ago the honorable mary guy myself
and a representative from manchester
got a bill through to change primary
school or to encourage
require primary schools
and preschools to do experiential
learning to do physical learning
so that the students had play that was
actually directed by somebody who knew
what they were doing they were a trained
educator and that actually improved the
fitness and coordination and
and mental ability
of the young children
remember that children learn through
play that's really important
so um
i'd also like to give a little shout out
to my friend
jerry frue mr frew who
was a student teacher when i started at
kearsarge
and um
then he became prince felts and came
back as our superintendent
and then moved on to bigger and brighter
things
so jerry's been through my uh throughout
my career and i think what he said was
really important it's kind of like the
maslow's
hierarchy of needs you know you can't
get to philosophy you can't get to
the peak of things
unless the your basic needs are being
satisfied and in schools right now in
community public schools
over regulation
underfunding
throw on that a little coveted
throw on that
extended learning opportunities that are
not
well coordinated or assessed or
accountable and i think
the people in the public school systems
know that they're at the basic level so
i know this is a leap of faith for them
but i think it's good to get it out and
say that yes
and i'm sure mr o'neill is going dr
o'neill will follow this up
that fitness and physical activity are
really really important and sometimes we
don't realize that until we're too old
and by then
um you know we work at it but
it isn't the benefit that we could have
had if we started at a younger age and
i'm open for any questions that you
might have thank you very much
representative represent hobson you have
a question
yes thank you for taking my question and
thank you for testifying today can you
tell me how many hours of physical
education the kids are getting right now
in this bill you reference
150 minutes per week yeah i think
at the high school level they they're
required to get one credit of physical
education
which basically is um
a year
of um courses so over over the four
years it's it's one credit in the
elementary school most elementary
schools
get physical education i believe in our
school district it was one period a week
and it was set up so that
the same period would then rotate the
next day to art the next day to music
you know and so on so that the the
students had that particular block
blocked out but they only had physical
education once a week so
if that day was a monday and think of
the holidays that we've had on mondays a
lot of times they'd go two weeks without
any physical education and at that age
they really
really it's important
follow-up
representative moffett thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh speaking of mr fruit when i
drove in here my
my light came on for low gas and so that
imagery keeps sticking in my mind but
your point about that i think
is is well taken
uh
it says this act will take effect 60
days after passage it's not my question
because i have one question and i want
to get right to it maybe somebody else
can ask about that
60-day piece my question
uh has to do with the asset the new
england association of schools and
colleges that does accreditation
for schools and colleges and uh do you
know i i do not but does the asic have
some current uh when they credit schools
do they have some current standard for
pe
um i haven't taught since 2004. um but
before that i was involved in several
accreditation programs and at that time
they did have physical education
standards i'm not sure what they have at
this at this very point but i know that
that was one of the things on
accrediting high schools
and as far as the 60 day notices i think
that is
kind of absurd
that schools you know we don't realize
that schools go from september to june
and everybody else is in the mindset
with budget and everything from january
to january you know just like our
session and so you know you're always in
a school situation you're always
thinking
um almost the full year ahead in order
to prepare for your courses your
curriculum and your budget and
even though you didn't ask but
just having you ask a question
reminded me about the sports
uh the participation in sports that um
representative baum talked about
uh
so the granddaughter is in gymnastics
and she's she's
act active and she's probably very
muscular but
um she hasn't had the ability to see
how that connects with fitness and talk
about nutrition and talk about
proper stretching and that sort of thing
and
whatever participation kids have in high
school sports it varies so greatly
the first year our school the last year
i taught actually was the first year
they decided they'd give a credit for
phys ed for going out for a sport
and i was the tennis coach
we have three courts
okay um and we share them with the boys
team
and all of a sudden normally i would
have 15 to 20 girls come out for visit
for tennis
um and at least
i would say 19 out of 20 knew how to
play tennis
that year i had 40 girls try out for
tennis
and
there was a no cut policy
put in
and i would say at least half of them
had never picked up a tennis racket the
only reason they were doing it was to
get a physical education credit
so
there's no way that i would i would
support that
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative tanner
i'm thinking about
the other testimony we heard and also
the reality of an elementary school
teacher
perspective
you are right usually it's a 45 minute
period once a week that elementary
students would get physical education
this bill requires four times that which
means four days a week of
of 45 minutes
i don't know how
that could happen
with one physical education teacher
where how did you come up with that
figure because it just is as much as
it's a good idea it just isn't feasible
i would think i think dr o'neill
probably addressed that because i think
that's a figure that comes from a
national point of view
one of the things that can be done and
should be done
and i'm not sure if you can even
legislate it but
for example kathy worked a lot with her
other colleagues or other elementary
school teachers
and gave them ideas about how they could
incorporate physical movement
and physical skills with math with
reading uh social studies they did you
know like where's waldo across the world
and and
the kids charted you know their walking
um distances and things like that so i
think it's something that
uh if you had a physical educator within
the district
uh that actually did the one period a
week but then
trained the other people within the
school system that you could come close
to it
i i this is the ideal it really is the
ideal and you can imagine how great kids
would be i know just teaching at high
school i had kids take extra phys ed or
they would come down to the gym or i had
this one boy that by the last period of
the day i knew he'd be there and i'd
hear the doors open and he'd
run across the gym and he'd pick up any
ball that was on the floor or anything
and start running around dribbling it
and everything and then he come to me
and he'd say
thanks and then he'd walk back to his
class
so represent tanner i have a question
for you sure and and looking back and
tapping some of your historical
understanding of physical education
um i'm married to a physical education i
thought it's kinesiology and so is uh
representative woodcock i believe is too
a number of folks here have it in the
family
um
i want to walk back to the 1970s
i don't know if uh i was trying to go
there i was teaching then i was teaching
also and back in the 1970s we had within
statute in maine and new hampshire
there are guidelines set out that you
had to teach so many minutes of
everything each week yep
that disappeared because we got into
thematic teaching and integrating
various subjects into you know together
like you do in pe you might have square
dance in a
history class yeah um but the the
question i have if we move back like
that
um i'm concerned i'm not concerned but a
hurdle is that
pe
in the elementary school and the
elementary school in our state can be k
through three grades four through six
could be middle school k through eight
could be elementary school
so perhaps we gotta identify grade
levels here
but we're also tying in the negotiated
agreements so many times pe music
library are tied to preps
prep for the teacher
and that's so identified like that even
in our funding law which we have
developed back in 2008
so
are we do we have those types of
obstacles that we're going to have to
deal with the negotiated agreement and
which grade levels this is specifically
talking about when we talk about 150
minutes per elementary school we get 30
minutes a day it could be 45 50 minutes
a day depending upon when that traveling
pe teacher is in your building right
traveling and with all the equipment in
the back of her car yes um
yes uh that's that's quite true and
that's uh one of the things i think as a
as a former teacher and a realist and
and also being on this committee
um that yes there's things in this bill
that need to be addressed
um and
like i believe um representative dushane
said this morning you know part of it is
setting guard rails and then
letting the local area figure out what
they can do within those guardrails but
i think the main reason i'm testifying
for this bill is that it's needed it
needs to come to the forefront it's
getting pressed obviously it's getting
pressed here and uh i think it's uh
important for everybody to realize
during no child left behind i remember
feeling left behind
because i couldn't be a highly qualified
teacher
and when i left teaching
the person that they hired for my
position wasn't a trained physical
education teacher it was an athletic
trainer that they thought could you know
throw the ball out
get get the kids moving around a little
bit and be an athletic trainer for the
sports teams and and she didn't last
very long
um
and
part of my emphasis is that you need
somebody who's trained a trained
educator i know some people think that
you know teaching is
is not a big deal but it is it and it's
it's really important in in all areas
um in physical education it's very
important thank you very much you're
welcome yes represent woodcock thank you
chairman
president good afternoon
um
a couple questions and you're right my
my wife is a physical education
instructor for
multiple three decades pluses and i was
on my way up a department chair of
health phys in high school
um different schools
i do have a question and i i was
teaching not as early as representative
labbitt in the same decade
when there was the same
same minute criteria for different
subject matters and massachusetts at the
time went to phys ed annually because as
you know his budgets constrict
first things that go out and use a phys
ed then guidance right now in that in
that order um so we're at the phys eddie
so they went uh into phys that must be
required annually
and the annually was in high school they
bring all the students in the gymnasium
for one hour once a year to show a film
to meet the criteria so i looked at the
new hampshire regulations that on the
bill that uh representative kenner put
in on 161 263 i didn't see a financial
note and i think there's a significant
financial impact here uh and i support
it i'm just telling you that these are
my concerns the other one is its
reference and i want you know this
better than i because i don't know a
whole lot about new hampshire physical
regulations
18910 as uh documented in the back part
of the conirex bill that you
co-sponsored
identified that there is no requirement
for physics
and you look at the other two areas in
the law of
89 and 49 and then the other one says
optional in the school board shall
uh or may in this case
so it's really almost a new requirement
uh and we've been talking about that all
all day and about requirements and as as
the uh spokesperson for the secondary
schools made it very very clear that
there's just teachers at this point in
schools that had enough and you and i
you and i both know that
at least i agree that all the courses
should be local and not prescribed by
some people in the concord
that being said
a course like this i do believe is
valuable my question is how where are we
going to get a
funding be willing your staff and three
more particularly where are we gonna get
the time within the
prescribed school day to fit it in and
what goes out
um right i guess it's it's priorities
you know um
the priorities for school and i i think
one of the reasons that i wanted to
testify on this is to say that physical
education and activity and i'm sure dr
o'neill is going to back this up
it should and has to be a priority i
mean it's it's something that
is
we can't take our children and put them
in classes and give them workbooks and
sit in front and and you know just
lecture to them
kids need to play kids needs to to learn
fitness kids need to learn to activity
they need to learn individual sports
so that they have lifelong activity
it's critical you know it's just
critical so
whenever you have a school you have a
pie and you have a certain amount of
money in a certain amount of time and a
certain amount of staff
and it's how you cut that pie up and i
guess what we're trying to say is
you know this is this is really i i
guess everybody that comes in with these
curriculum things are saying the same
thing but basically this is this is you
know life or death really i mean you can
be philosophical and
you know it doesn't really affect your
life or death but if you're not
physically fit
if you're
drastically overweight as a fourth or
fifth grader
um it's life or death you know it's a
it's a death sentence for you
so i think that's that's what the
importance is in the priority and
and there's the pie and as as mr fruit
said you know the pie isn't ready to be
split up it's not ready to talk right
now but um
it needs to be addressed in the future
when we talk about curriculum and
standards
thank you representative thank you very
much thank you are there further
questions of representative tanner not
saying thank you very much
next uh um
was there any priority you would like to
is it dr o'neill
uh thank you thank you dr konorick and
representative tanner thank you all of
you for considering this important bill
thank you the previous speakers for
emphasizing the fact that fitness is
indeed the foundation
has been the foundation of learning
since the time of aristotle
my name is dan o'neill i was the first
orthopedic surgeon at spear memorial
hospital in plymouth
i was team doctor for plymouth state
university holden school new hampton
school burke mountain ski academy
and multiple public schools
i have served as a as a physician for
the u.s alpine ski team in the us ski
jumping team
feeling i was missing a large component
of care i went back to school and
received a doctorate in exercise and
sports psychology from bu
from these vagis points i have observed
in the past 40 years the deterioration
of children's fitness and their
burgeoning addiction to two-dimensional
entertainment and ultra processed foods
this is what led me to write survival of
the fit and what leads me to speak with
you all today
when we were children the concern as we
stole our parents cigarettes was that we
would become addicted and suffer from
ephesians and lung cancer in our 60s
i am here to tell you that many of our
children are addicted and they are
already sick
they have diabetes high blood pressure
anxiety and depression now
they are not waiting until they're
adults
lack of fitness affects not just
physical and mental health but
everything about young people's lives
study after study shows that poor
fitness limits the ability to learn and
thus has a huge effect on academic
performance
we know without a doubt that a sedentary
child is not assimilating information or
thinking to their full potential
in other words there is no stem genius
without fitness
american children have less physical
physical education or gym class than any
child since school was made compulsory
for those students whose parents have
the means to combat this sedentary
lifestyle with enrolling them in sports
75 percent quit by the age of 15.
physiologically however we are the same
hunter-gatherer as we were 200 000 years
ago
we are at a program to walk or run 10
miles a day and eat a wide variety of
foods
hunter-gatherer as we have as dr kaner
described what i call a physical
identity
this is how we move how we explore the
outdoors how we respond to nature what
we do
children are born as active curious
motion loving beings with a built-in
physical identity
the solution theo to the obesity crisis
is simply not to allow physical identity
to lapse
daily physical education for every child
every day every year of school is our
only chance of maintaining a child's
physical identity to ensure a happy
healthy life
six children cost the state millions of
dollars today
daily physical education is a low-cost
low-tech game changer
finally when discussing cost and
implementation i can assure you that
physical education is less expensive
than the health care costs and as all
you know all of you in this committee
know seeing the recent numbers to
finance more mental health facilities
in the course of writing this book and
starting this campaign i have spoken to
many school administrators and
principals as well as teachers in my
last few minutes of testimony i would
like to highlight some of what they have
shared with me as covet and scheduling
issues did not allow their attendance
educators today are in an untenable
situation
we have been asked to put more into a
school day than is even metaphysically
possible
when no child left behind was passed in
2002 the main impetus was to improve
math and english scores
increased time in these subjects by and
large came from physical education
sadly in the past 10 years more time in
these subjects has not led to the hope
for results and test scores have stayed
essentially static
what has gone up however in the last 10
years is student obesity
this idea of enacting change by just
saying no to our students does not work
once they are addicted and we use that
word deliberately as we are indeed
addicted to media and bad food
this becomes a battle most parents and
ourselves as educators are ill-equipped
to fight
we will not solve this problem with a
negative
we must work so children never become
addicted and
make this happen with a positive
in new hampshire we have the ally of
mother nature thus there is no excuse
for not making sure our children are
addicted to going outside not call of
duty
we appreciate as educators that hbo 1263
could add another mandate for time to
the schedule however
any studies or data regarding education
that is more than 10 years old is
essentially worthless because the world
has changed
we are asking legislators to recognize
this and allow schools to make changes
that reflect educational challenges in
most educators and politicians grew up
in a much different world
if we can provide 180 days of activity
and impress upon parents the importance
of getting outside on weekends and in
the summer
this might be the greatest thing we can
do for academic achievement
we know the best guard against
alzheimer's is physical fitness why
would we not think the same would be
true for a young brain
here in the in the in the granite state
we have the teachers we have the
knowledge for this physical education
revolution we can improve our the health
thank you thank you very much doctor uh
i i have i have a question for you dr
neil do you want oliver ford
okay my question is dealing with um
have grandchildren
as most of us do
and we'd like to see them outside
playing rather than doing the xbox thing
so i'm also looking though at this 150
minutes and 225 minutes
uh does this include recess
or is that we talking about a direct
physical education instruction
by way of a class
yeah as representative tanner pointed
out
recess is not the same thing and the
older kids get the less they move at
recess and that is the crux of
everything
150 minutes of pe
and as a
liz savage will tell you having a proper
physical education instructor or
physical education assistant as i talk
about in the book
helping these kids stay moving for that
30 minutes a day in elementary school is
absolutely vital this way we're getting
their heart rates up but more
importantly we're getting their brain
stimulated and that's what's going to
happen when they go back into the
classroom we need to get their heart
rates up we need to get
their blood moving
standing around is not going to do it
and we know as the kids get older and
older they stand around more and more
which is why the middle and high school
numbers should be closer to 45 minutes a
day
this can be done but it is going to take
some arrangements and it is going to
take
some support with more pe teachers and
more pe teacher assistants which at this
point essentially don't exist
so a follow-up question doctor um is
there any benefit to the regular
classroom teacher in the elementary
school
taking them outside and running around
the soccer field prior to getting into
the academic star i did that every
morning as an elementary teacher first
thing we go run the field
everything that's exactly right and
that's becomes a culture one of the
schools that i'm involved with is
holding a school and and as you know
many of the private schools
they are
getting
athletics
physical education sports every day they
know the importance of doing this they
know that that's what stimulates brains
to assimilate
intellectual information that's what we
need to do in our public schools there's
absolutely no reason we can't do that
and it has to be a culture and as you
say
representative getting the math teachers
and the and the art teachers and making
sure in art class they're going out into
the woods and painting and doing
photography and getting the band
teachers to have them marching and and
and on on it's always about movement
everybody's in motion and it does have
to be something going from the lunch
ladies to the the custodians to
everybody on up through the
administrators to make sure that our
school is in motion and that's really
what's going to make the difference
is your uh
there you go
david and i've been fighting for this
mic all this session
um
i've done a lot of physical education
out of the school setting i'm a judo
instructor
i teach hunting and fishing and things
like that
and i've been engaged with children
outside the school
day
and perhaps it's because i went to
school as a child
when you walk to school
and so we had a pretty good workout just
getting to school and going home from
school
and that was uphill
[Music]
i grew up in
the
the issue of organized sports and
competitive sports of that sort was
always addressed through the cub scouts
to extra things to things done on
saturday through the kind of judo
courses i talked for the y
it was always another thing that was
done but it wasn't forced on the schools
to have to deliver it
it was probably out either out of
interest or parental interest or
whatever
and so i'm wondering if maybe
we're
overreaching and trying to require the
school structure to take up this which
is admittedly a time consuming process
but i never would have learned how to
fence if i had to do it in school they
would have been scared to death
you know we can't have seeds with swords
you can't have kids playing judo where
they might hurt you but you can
you know and so it's all a matter of of
setting it up and setting the conditions
for it but also having the motivation to
fulfill that need that you've identified
so so well
and i'm just wondering what you think
about the role of things outside of
school
well well clearly representative ford
you read my book already and um
so you point out three major topics here
number one
you have a physical identity
representative tanner representative
canuck have physical identities so many
of you that have already talked you have
a physical identity because you need to
get outside and after a day sitting in
this room you want to be outside you
want to get that dog and go for a walk
that's having a physical identity that's
what was established with you at a young
age
number two the community has to be a big
part of this we have put organized
sports into our school system and only a
small percentage of our school students
take advantage of those organized sports
that should be more a community issue
but every child deserves physical
education every child deserves to get
their heart rate up every day and that's
why we need to have this and again this
is 2022 it is nothing like when we were
kids when we went to school when we got
out of school and we ran in the woods
and we rode our bikes and we caused all
kinds of trouble
until the sun went down it is not like
that anymore because these kids have
this incredible of
evil that they're drawn to and they're
literally addicted to and this is the
other main
part of this we have to start the kids
at first grade and what i would when we
talk about changing the legislation what
i would say is we start with first grade
and then we go first and second grade
then first second third and we go on
from there because if we went into the
high school at kearsarge high school
today and we told the 16 year olds that
they have to get their heart rates up
for 45 minutes a day good luck with that
and i wouldn't put that on any principal
or teacher but kids have the physical
identity we just have to make sure they
thank you very much uh
so
you know as well as i do that the way
private schools get away with requiring
sports for every
student is they do it after school they
do it outside of academic hours
so i'm wondering if perhaps instead of
trying to impose something more on the
educational day which is already crammed
way too full in our schools here and
elsewhere in the country if we shouldn't
be looking at a model maybe where there
is more physical activity offered after
school
that you know we provide transportation
and the district i grew up in there were
two buses there was an after-school bus
there was an after sports bus so that
you didn't have to rely on mom and dad
to get home
and so it was just built into the system
and i'm wondering if that isn't a more
realistic approach to this
to have instead of trying to as i say
cram this into the academic day but but
have an extended day and maybe offer
something like fencing or tennis or
things that are not traditional team
sports but things that can be uh
somebody can carry with them for a
lifetime
there is no stem
without fitness
the problem is we're leaving behind as
soon as we make it and after school as
soon as we make it optional the rich
keep getting richer the kids that
already have their physical identities
the kids that have parents that are
willing to do that the kids that have
the wherewithal or the parental
wherewithal to do that we need to make
this for every child we can't let
anybody out
everybody's got to be doing this because
that's how important this is that's how
important and miss savage is going to
talk about this these fundamental
movement patterns are
we can't just keep letting the rich get
richer the what i thought you were going
to talk about is extending the school
day which is a black box that that i
would not want to open however
right now
the time that these kids are spending in
english and math and science is not
useful because they are not fit enough
to learn and that's an incredibly
important concept that again most of us
have a hard time understanding because
we don't know what it's like not to be
fit enough to actually learn but these
kids are not
thank you
uh representative mullen
mr chair and thank you dr o'neal i'm not
sure uh dr o'neill if you are the person
to answer this question
but representative woodside and i have
been
deep in uh yeah
have been deep in uh
research mode over here
trying to find out if in fact there is
a minimum time requirement for pe
how that compares to art and music
and english and math and
uh because i feel like when we're
looking at this bill and we're looking
at 150 minutes a week 255 minutes a week
or whatever i
i feel like i'm comparing apples and
oranges when i'm comparing a specific
time to a recommendation so
can you comment on that yes and for sure
miss savage we'll talk about this but
you're not comparing apples or oranges
you're comparing a family room to a
living room to an eat-in dining room
physical education is the foundation
that's not optional physical education
is the foundation after that now you can
talk about the different rooms and how
much room goes into english and how much
room goes into art the other thing that
i that i talk about in the book and by
the way almost all of your questions i i
believe are answered in the book
the other thing is that
we're not fighting physical education is
not fighting with art and music those
things are incredibly important
if i'm going to fight with anybody i'm
going to fight with math and i'm going
to fight with english because again
my obese diabetic
10 year old is not fit enough to learn
follow-up
and maybe this follow-up is for you mr
chair um is there anyone
that can tell me if there is a specific
time requirement no
you you know what no one can tell me or
no there is no there is nothing
we'll talk about that but no it is not
and this is what happens when you look
at the standards in every in in all the
states and granted this the new
hampshire standards that i talk about in
the book are now a few years old they
don't they don't touch that they're they
they don't touch that illinois touched
it and they're fighting now tooth and
nail in illinois illinois was the first
state to mandate this and it's been a
battle but we don't have to lose that
battle represent you'd have to go back
to the 19 latter part of the 1970s to
get what you're looking for yeah yeah
and you know and you go to 1866 in
california
two exercise periods a day in 1866 and
you want to talk about kids that were
walking up hill right
1866 in california two exercise periods
a day for every child
is that true for uh
math and
english
whatever they have very specific time
right they have minutes per week
and that's what we have to back off on
and allow educators
that that that uh leeway thank you
represent wood woodcock
thank you president
uh doctor thank you for taking my
question um because i hear you speak uh
as i said to representative tanner you
come from a physical health background
actually yesterday after when i was snow
showing just keep my dog walk um
obviously you've said multiple times
that uh fizz ed lifetime fitness becomes
a habit
and it's foundational to our academic
success and our health as we age and it
has to be taught as a habit
what struck me the most was
because i believe what you're saying but
what struck me was the progressive idea
of not uh and it's not addressed on this
bill but rather
rather the opportunity to integrate this
at grade one and then one two and one
two three so we're building this
lifetime support uh and to become a
habit for me so it'd be just a natural
way the second part that that uh
intrigued me about that carryover would
be a lot easier for school systems to
adopt that model as they integrate the
cost and the activity and the training
for physical educators uh for that
program and i would i hope that um
representative canaric and
representative tiana may be amenable to
thinking about an amendment that would
allow these time frames and and great
frames integrated in a progressive way
so it's not a big huge human cry at one
time and
and i just want to thank you for
bringing this forward with such passion
i couldn't agree more thank you
representative representative you had a
question
yes thank you when i brought up that
when i went to high school it was 45
minutes a day every day of the week for
four years but that was in miami and we
had outdoors and whatnot the problem is
now we have space problems in schools
where the gym in some schools isn't just
the gym
so that's a big issue the one issue
though too is what i brought up before
is alternative education
so if a student take for example is
doing gymnastics which is two to three
hours a night three or four days a week
all year
don't you think that would be an
alternative
rather than taking the phys ed in school
well you're asking the wrong guy here
representative because i'm a sports
medicine doctor in my day job
and
i deal with athletes and i can tell you
after having been the doctor at burke
mountain ski academy for many years
they are getting ski racers in 2022 that
are not fit
these are the top skiers in the country
top youth skiers in the country they
don't have the general all-around skills
that a bodhi miller had from running
around the woods of franconia for years
and so what we're seeing at these these
students that specialize in sports is
that they don't have the overall skills
and again miss savage could speak to
that
uh
for the next eight hours yeah which is
different than somebody doing gymnastics
but the other important point again is
that your granddaughter is developing
your physical identity and that's at the
end of the day really what i care about
are there any further questions
yes representative moffat
thank you mr thank you dr o'neill for
being here and i know plymouth state
used to have a pe requirement that
they've done away with which i was
disappointed anyway
um and this may not be a fair question
to you but the wheels are turning
and you just mentioned the obese 10 year
old and dr knurk had talked at these
statistics about 20 meeting criteria for
obesity
my question has to do with
uh do we need to have every single
student
i know we'd like to uh have for social
reasons and
but if the focus from what i'm hearing
from dr connorick and from you and and
representative tanner if the focus of
these people who as representative
tanner said or their lives were at risk
why is there some way that we could have
an assessment that included aerobic
proficiency upper body strength body
mass
index so if if somebody's really fit and
they know the standards that are
accepted they can proficiency out of
this and and my thinking is that if
as representative tanner said people
didn't want to take pe so they weren't
for tennis if somebody knew that if they
could run a certain
speed they didn't have to take pe i
think on their own some of these people
get fit outside of school but you see my
question can
why can't we just focus on the ones that
are really at risk instead of everybody
well a couple of reasons number one as
you say logistically it'd be very
difficult and then parents were trying
to figure out ways for their unfit kid
to get out of it and number two
you are revving up your brain so before
i sit for my board exam or before i
do an operation before i do anything the
best thing i can do is go out and go for
a good stiff walk or do some push-ups or
get my body going get my heart rate
going and get my brain going so
the fittest kid you know the fittest
olympic athlete is still going to
benefit before they take that test
before they uh sit in that calculus
class from getting their uh heart rate
up and getting getting some movement
thank you
are there further questions
not represent ford do you have a
question your your your lights on your
lights on
oh no no
thank you very much thank you all thank
you
you have to go now
mike
she's gonna have to go to a zoom here in
about
hello welcome
thank you and thank you for letting me
speak
my name is liz savage and i am a
passionate pe teacher for grades 7
through 12 at interlakes middle high
school in meredith i received my
teaching degree from plymouth state in
96 and i've been at my current school
for 13 years and like dr o'neill i've
had a front row seat watching the
deterioration of children's health
a big percentage of children between the
ages of 12 and 18 that i work with have
no physicality they cannot squat they
cannot run
they simply cannot move like young
athletic beings that they should be at
this age
one major problem is time i see high
school students for two quarters which
equals half a school year this is two
quarters out of the 16 that they are
enrolled in our four-year high school
middle school students they come every
other day for almost 25 to 30 minutes
this is extremely short compared to the
likes of english language arts social
studies science and math
this is a far cry from the 45 minutes of
moderate to vigorous physical activity
that is recommended daily
knowing there is limited limited time my
goal is to have the students move the
second they cross the threshold
any day we get outside is a good day but
this is still not enough with this
limited time not only are we not having
an effect of their on their physical
fitness we are not turning on their
brains for work in the classroom
every pe teacher has the education to
make things happen for our students we
just need the time
dr o'neill likes to call the pe teacher
the first violin of the school orchestra
without a strong body there will be no
strong minds our private schools have
appreciated this and why should our
public schools
receive any less
we also need to distinguish between
sports and pe they are not the same pe
and active outdoor play gives kids the
fitness to play sports
it is the rare school where even 50
percent of students are playing
organized sports that means a majority
of our kids are falling behind not only
in fitness but academic achievement
we cannot allow a two-tier system of
have and have-nots
all children deserve a basic level of
health and by maintaining physical
identity we can give that to them
ideally my job is to help graduate
students to the next level with the
tools needed for a healthy life
my job is to remind kids what is already
in their dna that playing and especially
playing outside is fun
and in fact a lot more fun than another
hour in front of a video game
30 to 45 minutes a day of increased
heart rate for every child every day is
going to burn hundreds of calories
and as alluded to help maintains
children's physical identity
i have a 12 year old and my husband and
i limit
the screen time as well as processed
food as well as making sure he gets
plenty of time outdoors
but as parents we are fighting a battle
against true forces of evil the folks in
silicon valley made the old addiction
companies of big tobacco look like
amateurs every child in 2022 is
continually being exposed to the these
addictive devices
and these forces are constantly looking
for ways to get our children to make one
more click and keep them from being the
active people that they should be
thanks so much for your consideration
for this important topic we'd be happy
to answer more questions of course and
we're hopeful that you get a chance to
look through the book thank you very
much are there questions of miss savage
yes representative luno sure thank you
very much mr sharon thank you very much
miss savage for joining us this
afternoon
um
excuse me
have um
some of your your you know uh colleagues
or classroom teachers
at interlakes have they started to
um
do things like including
student
movement in the in their uh
in their classroom activities too
i
push for that daily constantly i push
for it all the time i try to do a lot of
interdisciplinary work with science and
the health teacher
and
fortunately our new principal has a pe
background so
she is to encouraging people to get
outside and walk and move so
yes
but
some people
like their classrooms um but i push for
it daily sure great thank you very much
are there further questions
and the last card which i have up here
is uh
thank you chairman lad my name is ciao
kelly i'm from hooksett and i'm here to
oppose the bill um
hb
i came from vietnam communist country
and when i got here i was about 20 years
old and i have no clue what a gay person
means
i have
no understanding of all these gender
stuff
and i thank god for that because i still
preserve my innocence and understanding
because
as a child in a school they should be
focusing on studying
not
learning about sexual change transmitted
disease
and drugs and alcohol and hivs
i mean elementary school
as an adult
i don't focus much time on understanding
about much about these things myself
why do we inject this poison into the
kid's mind
at such a young age
we're talking about physical
exercise and stuff like that for kids is
good
but this is not all in the this bill
it's have all kinds of crazy stuff in
here
this bill is totally about physical
education all the other language you see
there that's not in bold print is in law
okay
so i mean physical education out in the
public
is safe and fine for the kids but i
oppose this bill because
with all these
like introducing like um prevention for
like birth control for the kids then we
have a bigger problem
which uh children teenagers having
children and then leading to a lot of
abortion and now we're introducing a lot
of
these um
you know
inappropriate education for elementary
school
this will lead to bigger problems for us
to deal with in the future so i would
like to if you could please oppose this
bill 1263
thank you thank you very much are there
other questions
i don't have any other pink cards up
here so with that i'm going to close the
okay
2 30
a little bit late
you know what's always bothered me
though is that you can have a kid going
out in
indoor outdoor track like my
granddaughter's my own daughter
for 120 minutes after school and yet
they still have to take a pe course
and they're gone from school early
sometimes and they're missing they could
be using the time within pe during the
school to do the work that they're
missing
where did that come from
these guys have another meeting coming
in here
okay for those which are on the
committee we're going to take a couple
minute break here stand up stretch it
out a little bit
then we'll come back and start the next
bill
community
you
and then uh nate is here
from d.o.e
questions
push-ups
okay uh folks we're ready to go ahead
with the next bill which is hb 1367.
this is relative to civics instruction
in schools
with that i'd like to welcome
representative hobson
to present the bill
thank you chairman ladd and thank you
honorable colleagues this is going to be
very short
uh thank you for the opportunity to
bring this bill to the committee's
attention you'll recall that last year
the house passed hb 320 requiring a civ
civics competency assessment for high
school graduation
schools are already working to implement
that measure and parents especially are
excited about this new emphasis on
common fundamentals
during last summer's review process it
was brought to our attention by
diana fenton that the department of it
at and the department of education that
we could fine-tune the statute and
improve it a bit with language
to reaffirm the provision allowing for
accommodations for students on an
individual education
individualized education program
this proposed
minor language modification seeks to do
that thank you for your time and there
is a copy of the language
going around
so
if you have any questions i
am joined today by nate greene from the
department of education
thank you
are there any questions of
representative hobson yes represent
woodcock
thank you
chairman now i know why you're cleaning
the microphone there you go okay you're
speaking next thank you and i'll leave
it clean oh you're a good woman okay
thank you listen
i want to make sure i'm clear on this so
the only
change
you're making to this uh current bill
current law
is the accommodation piece yep that's
right
easy peasy so
okay because i was reading i i was
reading it incorrectly uh because i'm
looking at the first part but you're
you're telling me that lines two three
and four that's already in law
well i don't have a copy of the
legislation with the lines in it uh that
reference the line right it's talking
about a requirement for local competency
assessment
the us government and then outlines the
multiple pieces of that yep
as one
and then two it outlines the
the non-assessment
uh the non-training
testing examination that we give kids to
get a graduation diploma which is the
immigration exam which is different from
your part a
so you're telling me the part the part
that began in the assessment of
uh
government and civics is already in law
yes exactly
well i believe it is um
what we were changing was or
amending was just
the provision for
teachers to accommodate individual
education plans
are you do you still have a question on
it no i i'm trying to decide if she was
answering it or were you both thinking
yeah i'm trying to decide if i was
answering we're both thinking on that
question because it's not clear
thank you let me ask um
so
so representative before you uh
uh to
ask of reps and hobson i'm following up
to represent woodcock i'm just trying to
find out everything that's bold in here
is a change to this bill is that correct
so now
okay in there there's like a both and an
and down there as well that's part of
this
okay then uh could you explain either mr
green or or represent hobbs and
sure absolutely
uh so for the record my name is nate
green i'm with the new hampshire
department of education uh there are two
changes uh that you see here as you
mentioned those changes are in bold
one is the addition of schools required
to provide accommodations accommodations
a specific language within the special
education program of schools so we
wanted to make sure that that was
included for students who have ieps that
will be required to take this exam
and then
previously schools were already required
to administer a locally designed
competency-based assessment the law had
added in addition to that a requirement
that schools administer the uscis
citizenship examination
and
because schools were required to do both
of those things but the language at the
end of the bill said that they could
submit one or the other of those pieces
of data to the department the department
felt that because both were requirement
it was important to have the sets of
data for both of those and that's why
the addition of the both and as opposed
to the either or was added to the
legislation so the requirement to
administer the exams are already part of
law
but it wasn't clear what the department
was collecting
and so we could have had a situation
where half the schools in the state gave
us data from the citizenship test and
half the schools gave us data from the
local competency assessment despite the
fact that they're required to do both
and we felt if they're required to do
both and we're collecting data then we
should have the and in there that it was
important to have the data from both
sets of exams
thank you representative woodcock thank
you chairman thank you so much that that
does clarify the two i knew there were
two there if i could just ask one follow
up on that regard thank you all that um
and the part nate of top that's already
in law it talks about the local
assessment
is there any numeric number
that is required or grade
uh
alpha uh letter grade required for the
local assessment to be considered or is
it p or f
yeah so this there there's a requirement
of 70 on the civics test but on the
local competency based examination there
was not a certain percentage requirement
because there's a variety of different
ways that schools
can measure that assessment
okay thank you thanks my question
uh represent you
representative can you put the mic on
please
thank you mr chair
with a simple pass fail grade suffice so
they don't have to have a numeric grade
it would and in fact that's what we've
done this past year because there was a
variety of different ways schools could
grade the assessments it wouldn't be we
wouldn't be able to compare students if
one student had an abcd one student had
a level one two three four
one student had a pass fail so what we
asked each school to do is just provide
the department with data on which
students were proficient on the exam and
which students were not proficient so it
was it was really just two choices and
that's the data we collected thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
does this apply to
all schools all public schools so
uh
it yes i believe it does because this is
part of the rsa 189 as opposed to the
minimum standards this would be all
public schools which i believe includes
charter schools as well and private
schools
uh in this case i don't believe it
at the start of 189
colon 11 it says in all public and
private schools in the state and it's
part of that
chapter so i'm just wondering if it's
goes with it
that's a good question
okay and
could i have a follow-up yes you may so
uh who at the state department is
collecting the data is it you is it your
division it is okay thank you
further questions mr represent moffatt
thank you miss share and thank you for
taking my question um
i'm certainly american as a clerk here
and i'm also was an original sponsor of
the original bill
and so just so
i'm clear i just saw the uh
the new language uh this separate sheet
that just was passed around as i
understand it
d-o-e
identified two
pieces of the current law that could be
improved uh with different wording and
those two pieces are
number one
the original in the current language
said and says that schools may modify
naturalization exam for a child with a
disability in accordance with an iep
so that's changed to
uh it's actually added to that schools
it now says are required to provide
accommodations so whereas before it said
apply accommodations to ieps now it says
they're required to provide
accommodations so that's that's the the
one change there is that correct
yes
thank you and then the second little
piece of this
uh which you just spoke to and just so
that i and we're all clear
the second piece clarified
uh
it's
originally it said
the law said that the two exams would be
taken
but this clarifies the language and says
both
exams will be taken and that the uscis
test uh
is mandatory essentially is that is that
accurate
yeah so my understanding is that's
already part of the legislation that
schools uh are required to do both of
those pieces and so the change that
we're making here is the department is
collecting the data on both of the
examinations
and all students will be required to
take the 2020
version of the uscis test
yes and that's part of the legislation
already in law so that part has not
changed okay uh thank you very much
further questions represent woodcock
thank you just the clarification um
reverend led this this document that
receives what is this document i
i'm not looking at that document i'm
using this
language that i printed off this morning
okay and
so um may i yes
representative hudson the the language
that we received on
is different
than the language that you just gave us
in the supplemental piece of paper
and i say that uh specifically as it
regards the 128 question
civics exam
and the language you gave us on the
supplemental sheet that is deleted
from the
the uh
document yet an alarm on the chain that
you presented is still in the dark
internet
yeah um so i was double checking the
language required the language that
changed uh last night and i didn't have
a chance to look at this this morning um
so when i i printed it off i didn't
compare the two and i'm i was wondering
which one are we using i guess we are
using the bill that's been submitted to
us this sheet right here is not being
discussed okay thank you thanks for my
question thank you
thank you chair loud
not seeing any for either folks thank
you very much thank you thank you
representative hobson can i get a pink a
pink uh stuff from you
are there any other cards for this
negative
thank you very much so this will
health 13670 now
yep is that lady coming back
oh we should have it for this one this
is the one you like this one oh this is
the one
geez
i'm not going to worry about it yeah
right
now
jody from uh whatever town
jody from
keene
okay amanda elizabeth
keane
yeah
okay
so
represent all children
oh i didn't see that down here okay
all right
okay
well there's a lot of them
yeah
okay i'd like to open up this hearing
for hb 1533 relative to health education
curriculum in schools
and i'd like to uh welcome amanda told
to represent amanda told to the
hearing
welcome
thank you committee members and chairman
lang i'm introducing house bill 1533
with me today i have miss emily murphy
she is a violence prevention educator
who has been teaching this type of
curriculum in southeastern new hampshire
for 20 years she does have testimony but
i will be deferring questions that are
specific to the classroom experience to
her
again my name is amanda elizabeth tull i
represent the city of keene at large i'm
here to introduce my bill hb 1533 which
would add age appropriate instruction on
the meaning of consent
respect for personal boundaries and
sexual violence prevention to the
curriculum
this legislation helps keep our youngest
granite staters safe by giving them the
tools they need to establish and respect
others boundaries
build healthy relationships and to
protect themselves from abuse
education and strategies related to
consent can help stem the tide of
domestic and sexual violence
the psychological and physical impact of
non-consensual sexual activities can
last a lifetime there should be very
little partisan ideology associated with
wanting to prevent
this type of harm
as it currently stands in statute 189-10
the state of new hampshire does and can
dictate what topics are taught in
schools
from health and physical education to
sexual well-being topics the precedent
for preventing harm and promoting
well-being through education is clearly
established
this legislation has been endorsed by
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence a highly
trusted organization with a long history
of bipartisan work
this legislative proposal is also
endorsed by the new hampshire youth
movement and end sexual violence on
campus new hampshire
these are two groups who clearly
represent populations who are deeply
impacted by the lack of education
related to consent
i strongly encourage everyone to closely
read the written testimonies provided in
support of this bill
these have been given to us by parents
students and organizations
they provide powerful and heartfelt
statements about the importance and
urgency of our work
according to empirical data
20 percent of women in the u.s report
being sexual assault survivors
furthermore there appears to be
something amiss societally and
systematically when 25 percent of men
admit to having caused non-consensual
sexual harm
as we will hear today
these concerns around harm are
particularly present for adolescents and
young adults
government has a moral imperative to
address very real social issues that
impact nearly every citizen when we
consider both sides of the trauma cycle
this is not a radical idea
we already teach our students about
physical education
hygiene and the impact of alcohol and
drugs
we clearly share a vision of wanting to
keep young people safe and healthy
teaching consent is something that is
preventative and already normalized in
many other states
several states and the district of
columbia already require consent to be
taught as part of public school
curriculum
these states are california hawaii maine
maryland new jersey oregon vermont and
west
virginia this legislation has his
co-sponsors
two retired public school teachers a
liaison for the haven crisis center a
psychologist a social worker and two
state representatives who are sexual
assault survivors and have been open
with their stories
a tremendous amount of thought was put
into this i hope that you will pass this
common sense legislation that is an
essential public safety measure and will
undoubtedly advance our shared interest
of protecting children adolescents and
our young adult granite staters
thank
before we go on you somebody that has
one more thing i
one more thing i just want to let um you
know that i have the um with me the
endorsement of the legislation from end
sexual violence on campus and so i want
thank you very much and thank you for
the courtesy of being able to testify on
the front end
i will say that you're all running at a
better clip than we are across the hall
[Laughter]
so thank you esteemed colleagues thank
you for your service to new hampshire
and for your time and attention today
and i want to begin with a simple and
powerful statement
my body belongs to me
and i want to follow that with
your body belongs to you
and that's a message that most of us
internalize and use as our lodestar in
our daily interactions we say excuse me
tell me
when walking around each other in the
hallways and here at the lob and for
those of us that go to a gym or a yoga
studio or dance class we make space for
each other around so that we can move
our bodies without crashing into each
other and possibly causing harm
when we're in line in the cafeteria
downstairs we have an expectation that
we can get in line for our meal without
being groped pinched or subjected to
harassing language about our bodies
learning how and when
and why we should behave like this
is important to our safety and when
these boundaries are breached we should
also know that we have the knowledge and
support that is never too late to tell
someone and that we can get help
unfortunately across new hampshire our
students are not learning the basics of
personal body safety and we have the
statistics to back it up according to
research done at the university of new
hampshire
child sexual abuse cases are on the rise
between 2017 and 18 we saw a 26
increase in cases in the 2020 annual
report of the granite state children's
alliance which is the umbrella agency
of the 11 child advocacy centers in new
hampshire
um they stated that during the first
week of the covet 19 shutdown
new hampshire dhhs reported that the
department of children youth and
families central intake office
experienced a 50 percent drop in reports
of suspicious child abuse and suspicions
of child abuse and neglect and during
this same time granite state children's
alliance saw a significant drop in the
cac referrals from law enforcement and
dcyf and this was not because there was
a decline in child abuse it was the
result of a decline in the personal
interactions between children and those
adults most likely to co to report those
concerns
in the return to school since then title
ix coordinators guidance counselors
teachers and administrators are asking
for programming saying they need it now
high school students are reaching out
and asking for support groups and help
we have data from the centers of disease
control and prevention and there is a
graphic on the back page of the
testimony that you just received that
show one in three female rape victims
experienced it for the first time
between the ages of 11 and 17 years old
and one in eight reported that that
occurred between the ages
before the age of ten
nearly one in four young men rape
victims experience it for the first time
between the ages of 11 and 17 years old
and one in four reported that it
occurred to them before the age of 10
and a piece that is missing from my
testimony but i want to re i want to
make sure you know this the average
reporting age
of an adult who experienced child sexual
abuse during these times that are that
are documented
the average age is 52.
so people hang on to that information
for a very very long time
we think that schools are the best place
to reach the most children
to talk about personal body safety and
that it is their right they have the
right to be safe they have the right to
keep their bodies safe
to clarify
this language is not about sex education
as i explained in an interview last
thursday with peter biello on new
hampshire public radio
adding elements
of consent awareness to sex education
would be a welcome supplement to that
particular curriculum
the meaning of consent respect for
personal boundaries and sexual violence
prevention education are much broader
than sex education this language
proposal is not about sex education
children need to learn the basics of
sexual violence prevention healthy
boundaries and our friendships
relationships with their teachers
coaches scout leaders faith leaders and
family members are critical it should be
common knowledge for students that
touches in the private areas are never a
secret
students coming out of new hampshire
high schools
should be well versed in consent
this type of programming is what we
propose in house bill 1533 currently
only some of new hampshire students have
access to age-appropriate instruction on
the meaning of consent to respect for
personal boundaries and sexual violence
prevention only some
so as policy makers i'll ask you to look
at this from a risk management
perspective with this
with this particular rsa
in this rsa we have a section called
emergency response plans and it says
that all public schools chartered and
private schools have to have emergency
response plans like fire drills and
active shooter drills
and i have given you a copy on page
three
of um the 180 189 64 the emergency
response plans this is built into
statute
and then in our um
in our recommendation is that we would
like to
build upon an emergency response
so let's talk about this emergency
response fire safety most of us who have
had children who have attended
new hampshire elementary schools know
that the day that the local fire
department comes to school with a ladder
truck is an awesome day
it's amazing we hear about it for weeks
every day every school in new hampshire
in accordance with the law
which is on page three
conducts fire drills for students while
they are in school
additionally children as young as pre-k
in kindergarten can tell you what to do
if their clothing catches on fire and we
all know this stop drop and roll that's
personal body safety stop chop and roll
is a message that gets repeated over and
over and over again until it becomes
reflexive that's called proactive
prevention messaging
with the additional language we propose
to be added to our rsa 189 10
schools will have the obligation under
statute to provide prevention primary
prevention education for what we know
is a real and documented risk of injury
children have more of a chance
of being a probability
of being sexually assaulted than they do
of catching on fire
we should be teaching them about
personal body safety and that
when and if someone touches them that
makes them feel hurt confused or scared
a few years ago prior to my serving in
the house i had the privilege of working
with an advocate
who accompanied a family to the
stratford county
child advocacy center and she was there
to support a family whose young son
was one of a number of children who had
been abused by a single perpetrator
and the family of course was distraught
as one as a family would be
um there's distraught that this had
happened they were distraught about now
what comes next
and um and they were um really upset and
concerned about how this little boy this
little third grader
was going to cope with the forensic
interview process
when the interview was over
the little boy who had lightning mcqueen
light up sneakers and a wiggly tooth
came out and he walked out of an
interview room where he had just been
part of a forensic interview about his
sexual assault and he was actually
beaming and this really struck the
advocate because that's unusual to have
a child like beaming ear to ear
and the family's response was like how
are you feeling how are you doing
you know like very would
want to support him in the best way but
really not expecting that response
and he said i'm good i'm good the puppet
people told me i could keep telling
until i got help
and i did
and it worked this little boy was a
student he was a third grade student at
a school that really valued violence
prevention education and he had been
exposed to the personal body safety
curriculum that age-appropriate
programming began for him with friendly
puppets in kindergarten
first grade and second grade
his he was now in third grade and his
school his classroom was not scheduled
to have that program again till later in
the spring so we know that violence
prevention education works
and
lastly i'll share an experience of
our educators working with an eighth
grade classroom and there was a young
girl in the classroom who was new to the
school within a year or two and she had
been sexually abused as
um as a really really young child in
elementary school but as she has moved
away and um she had been told over and
over and over again during the abuse
that she could not tell anyone
and that this was
this was not abuse
but she learned through that program
that what she experienced and the reason
she felt so hurt confused and scared was
that it was abuse and this educator gave
her the permission
and the empowerment
to say that happened to me and to get
the help that she needed
so we just believe every student from
nashua to pittsburgh
lyme to conway
hinsdale to sanborn ville and every
school district in between should have
this curriculum integrated into their
education and i ask you to recommend
house bill 1533 ought to pass
thank you very much thank you are there
any questions for the
speaker right now
not seeing any hands thank you very much
i appreciate that and thank you and we
have an educator here in the room to
answer your questions about what it
looks like in the classroom too thank
you
thank you uh chairman ladd and members
of the committee uh for the record
my name is joshua query and i represent
hillsborough 16 which is manchester's
ward 9.
um i'm here to testify in favor of hb
i will keep this brief as i do know the
workload that your committee does have
and i also have to get running back up
to
hhs
as soon as i'm done
um
so nationally about one in eight females
and one in 26 male high school students
report having experienced sexual dating
violence in the last year
and 26 percent of women and 15 percent
of men who were victims of context
sexual violence physical violence and or
stalking by nate by an intimate partner
in their lifetime first experienced
these or other forms of violence by that
partner before the age of 18.
according to the cdc
the supporting uh
supporting the development of healthy
respectful and non-violent relationships
has the potential to reduce the
occurrence of teen dating violence
and prevent its harmful and long-lasting
effects on individuals there are
families and the communities where they
live
during the pre-teen and teen years it is
critical for both for youth to begin
learning the skills needed to create and
maintain healthy relationships
these skills
include knowing how to manage feelings
and how to communicate in a healthy way
teaching our young granite staters these
valuable skills early on will help set
them up for a more successful prosperous
and happy life
thank you for your time i will be
emailing you all
uh the links to those statistics that
way you can have them for yourself thank
you very much are there questions for
the representative
yes representative moffat
thank you miss sheridan i know uh
representative schiller had to leave and
i guess you do too and oh she's still
here um
so i very sympathetic the intent of the
bill in
having been around a little while
looking at language
uh and also understanding uh how lawyers
or attorneys sometimes look at language
uh
i saw a woman in the back room look up
at me i said attorneys but i think it's
important because um
we need to
look at how these words might be
interpreted by simon so i simply i see
age-appropriate instruction
in age appropriate i'm not sure that
there's consensus on that maybe there is
you're all ahead of me on on this uh
what is age-appropriate instruction and
then the meaning of consent again i
you're way ahead of me on this i'm just
looking at this which is our job is to
look at the language
uh what is the meaning of consent i i
don't know
but i suspect there may be some folks
whose meaning of consent uh might differ
from someone else's i i don't know
that's my question along with personal
boundaries personal boundaries comes to
some cultural things a lot of us have
traveled around the world
and you know in some cultures people get
in your face and that's how they do
business and other cultures uh that
they're just different cultures so
there's a cultural concern there so
anyway my question is uh in terms of
definition of personal boundaries
age-appropriate instruction meaning of
consent is do is your consensus on those
i don't know
yeah um
i think some of the reason for
uh
i i definitely see what you're getting
at is that there is a little bit of i
don't want to say vague but
wiggle room in these definitions um it's
that way that we can give our teachers
and our school districts and our local
control uh
like you know school boards or whatever
that may be the ability to kind of tweak
and adjust
to those different uh needs of their
communities so i think the perfect
example of your
your cultural
reference there um
you know what might be needed down in
nashua or manchester where we do have a
lot of
international people going to our public
schools might be very different than
somewhere up north where there might not
be as many
people of different cultures if that
makes sense
thank you i'm tracking
you wanted to have some you said wiggle
room so i guess there's follow-ups you
wanted some wig room so by not being too
prescriptive you allow
uh i guess districts to have some
discretion in terms of how they
implement the intent of the measure is
that fair to say
correct correct great great thank you
are there further questions
welcome
thank you for having me can you hear me
okay not used to speaking in a
microphone
my name is renee montiel i'm from keene
new hampshire i am a birth and
postpartum doula
a childbirth educator and a reproductive
can you move the mic a little closer to
you yes is this better yeah it's much
better all right thank you
so
i also have two school-aged daughters
and um
i started teaching them about consent at
a very early age you know whether it's
uh
um
you know my one daughter wanting to bite
her sister's toes i'm like no that's you
don't have consent to abide your sister
you know things start really early on
the
on the home front
teaching consent
is teaching life skills
teaching consent is also about giving
all of our children the tools they need
to navigate society safely
with confidence
and being able to hold firm boundaries
with a strong sense of body sovereignty
it's about helping our children and
teens learning to respect both their
desires and the desires of others
it's about learning that other people's
bodies don't exist to serve
others teaching consent is teaching a
one may ask if it's necessary to teach
teaching younger children starts with
just teaching space body in touch it's
about giving permission whether it's
hugs or borrowing personal items
as an educator i've been approached many
times by parents asking me to
help them either discuss this with their
teens and their children or
do it for them because they feel rather
uncomfortable and their teenagers don't
want to listen to them
i've also been asked to speak in at the
waldorf school to teach a course on
bodily autonomy and sexual reproductive
health
studies show that teaching consent does
not increase sexual activities in teens
that's something that's really important
for people to understand because much of
the sexual activity is being done under
pressure
teaching consent would better prepare
them to navigate these situations with
confidence
i've also seen the effects of what it is
to navigate society without being taught
these skills i teach informed consent to
my pregnant clients if i've seen too
many pregnant women
just trying to have some bodily autonomy
in the birthing room learning these
skills later in life are still good but
wouldn't it be better if we didn't have
to
ultimately teaching consent is teaching
respect for other people's boundaries
and being taught to enforce your own and
i believe that's something that we all
want for our children
thank you for your time
one question
maybe as uh working in the field here
you may have some understanding
um three or four years ago we had a bill
coming up dealing with discipline in the
schools
and the bill read to the fact that
a teacher could not touch
the student without the student first
giving permission
we were concerned
as a committee yes that
if you see two kids scuffling going down
to the lunchroom
the teacher probably an error if they
didn't put the hand on the shoulder of
somebody and try and say
slow down let's get it together
is that then going to be interpretive if
the teacher does this and this to
happens oftentimes the teacher will walk
around the room and put the hand on the
shoulder of the kid or
or help out you know with peopleship
what have you is that a personal
boundary
so this is a really good question my
mother is a special educator and the um
for three school districts in los
angeles
and she has at times had to restrain
children there's been times when someone
has you know a second grader
has had a pair of scissors and tried to
stab another child you know when it
comes to safety this happened when it
comes to safety this is a completely
different matter i don't feel that
that's a matter of teaching
consent or boundaries you are
intervening in a dangerous situation you
know and having a fight on the school
yard and separating
you you are acting
in the name of safety that's a
completely different thing is
thank you very much that's where some
language yes
lawyers love it yes they do they very
much do and i guess that's where we'd
have to be very careful because i do
understand that like on a personal level
listening to my mother being a special
ed director for three schools
we have a lawyer in the room they're
always going to smile when we mention
the word lawyer
[Laughter]
okay are there further questions we have
several in the room that's right and
down to my right
okay no more questions thank you very
jody um
from keane
i i can't
i apologize jody i cannot
we both can't i write in all capital
letters so you can understand it i've
just gotten so bad that you can't
understand those either
that's okay welcome jody thank you
um
my name is jody newell and i'm from
keene
i am here today to speak in support of
hb 1533 regarding the inclusion of
consent in the sexual education
curriculum
as a mother of two boys entering their
teens this topic is especially relevant
to my own family
i have always tried to keep
communication open and dialogue ongoing
in these conversations i've found the
aspect of consent to be inextricable
inextricable
from the broader topic
this is my personal experience but to
clarify the significance of consent and
sexual education i'd like to quote some
folks far smarter than i am
just about a year ago boston university
school of law published a paper
discussing the results of various
studies regarding consent in sex
education
um and so now i'm quoting from them from
this paper consent is not i mean sex is
not sex without consent it's rape
a columbia university uh indica study
indicated that those who receive
training and how to refuse sexual
advances were less likely to be sexually
assaulted in college equipping students
with the ability to set their own
boundaries is important but teaching
students to recognize and respect those
boundaries and others is just as
necessary to prevent sexual uh violence
merely giving students the tools to help
them potentially get out of a situation
they don't want to be in is not enough
because it does not express the
importance of consent in sexual
interactions as long as people fail to
recognize and respect the consent of
others there will always be
uncomfortable or dangerous situations to
try to get out of it's mopping up water
from the overflowing sink without
turning off the tap
continuing on they say for younger
children consent education reassures
them that they have a say in what
happens to their bodies something many
children are not aware of and it teaches
them to respect other people's choices
as well
as students age understanding consent is
a concept that allows them to form
fundamental understandings of what
healthy relationships look like with
others look like
beyond a reduction in sexual violence
and misconduct these are important life
skills that reach far beyond sexual
situations
clearly teaching about consent and
physical boundaries is important it's
essential and i hope that you will all
vote in support of this addition to the
sexual education curriculum
thank you very much are there any
questions
um next uh on the deck here is larry
welkowitz
from keane a lot of people from keen
i am a representative is that
oh you say what have you representing
self okay you're not okay yeah
okay
uh
my apology then for not inviting the
upper lord that's fine mr chair thank
you for the opportunity to speak
uh my name for the record is larry
welkowitz
i am a state house representative
representing cheshire district four i'm
also the chair and professor of
psychology at keene state college
i'm also a licensed new hampshire
licensed psychologist and i'm going to
limit my remarks just to my clinical
experience
and
in support of house bill 1533
of which i'm also a co-sponsor
i um
for the past 30 years i have worked with
a variety of at-risk populations
including children and adults on the
autism spectrum and i want to use this
as an example people with autism
have particular social
deficits that make it difficult for them
to understand the intentions of others
they have what we call difficulties with
theory of mind understanding what other
people are thinking
and feeling
as a result they often get in some
trouble sometimes in middle school and
high school and at the college level as
well
the trouble they get into is
misunderstanding the intentions of
others and so
a girl in school is nice to a boy and
the boy misunderstands and starts to
follow that girl around and pursues her
aggressively this leads to problems in
the school often i get called in to sort
of unpack
and explain
what is happening in all of these cases
what we do is we teach consent skills to
the student to the student who's gotten
into trouble this is amazingly effective
and it's very easy to do we simply teach
the student how to obtain consent at
every level of advancement
simply
is this okay is it okay if i ask you out
is it okay if i follow you to your
cheerleader practice is it okay if i
take your hand
simply
getting consent at every level of
romantic advancement
when we teach those simple consent
skills those kids no longer get into
trouble as we were doing this for years
we started to realize that this was
probably a good idea to teach other
people as well in fact
i even teach my friends how to do this
and we prevent
we prevent these problems and these uh
accusations of sexual misconduct
tremendously by doing this simple
type of consent uh training so um
what i want to say oh so one question
that some of you may have is why not
leave this to families to do this is the
sort of thing that maybe families could
do and i agree wouldn't that be nice if
families did that
i don't know about you but my parents
never did that with me they didn't teach
me
those things
at least not in those in those ways so
if we teach the simple skill to our
children we'll prevent scores of
problems from occurring
and it could be your own kid it could be
your for a lot of state legislators your
grandchild perhaps from being accused of
misconduct or for getting in in this
sort of trouble
hb
1533 addresses this problem quickly and
effectively
i'm reaching across the aisle on this
one please support uh this bill so uh we
can move it to the house thank you house
floor thank you
thank you thank you very much
representative are there any questions
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i i did teach consent back in like the
80s and 90s and sex ed
and i found
it very striking to me
that
even people who don't have autism
are very confused kids are very confused
and i was wondering
what i know drugs and alcohol were part
of it and certainly the popular culture
was part of it but
is there a
have you found
uh different reasons why
uh certain people are really
so confused about consent and and how
how it can happen
that um
for example in my class i had a girl who
had suffered incest for years and didn't
realize it until we did this in in the
class it was very striking
um how that would how that occurs that
they
you know the confusion with consent i
think other than you're autistic
that's an excellent question i think you
know just like autism occurs on a
spectrum
so do social skills in general you know
some of us are better than others at
this
hey i'm talking to a bunch of state
legislators some of you tend to talk at
people rather than with people but
that's the nature of the
of the job um this requires a very
specific tuning into what other people
are doing their eyes how their eyes are
are are moving facial expressions body
movements and words that people say
and so there's a broad spectrum in terms
of people's skills level in picking up
on those skills
but if we teach people to and why would
we expect anyone to be a good mind
reader right you know so if we say look
assume the word assume that you can't
read other people's minds then just ask
and i think a lot of consent skill
training is just it's very simple it's
just asking people
thank you representative mullen
thank you mr chair and i'm over here
behind the speaker representative
welkowitz
from your professional experience
have you found that people confuse
no means no
with
the aspect of consent
and what i'm asking is because i think i
know i was guilty of it myself with my
own daughter that because she was
assertive
i felt like she had all bases covered
because i figured she would just knock
somebody's block off if they came nearer
and uh
and the answer was no
but there's more to consent am i correct
than just no
yeah there
there is more than just no and you know
getting back to your point i think one
i have to say parenthetically that
let's face it we have a generation of
kids who are who are being exposed to
pornography and things like that where
they're getting really strange messages
about romantic
behavior because pornography is not does
not equal romantic
behavior so i think that also
contributes to this idea in terms of
romantic activities what know
what no means because they're seeing a
very different thing
uh in social media and
and
online pornography but yeah i think and
assertive behavior is good we want to
teach people to be able to tell people
what they need and what they want and to
be persistent i think that probably is a
positive factor but then i think when
you add this one extra layer of um
teaching everyone
that
no means no and that you must obtain
consent at every level i think that's
the point of uh amanda tolle's
legislation really is that is that if
everyone knows
that at every level if someone says no
then you stop then we're going to
thank you very much i have a question
for you representative
um
this this uh change to the statute comes
underneath health education instruction
and as a
intermediate school principal for years
grades four through
right up through grade eight at times
through six
um
we dealt with uh this area of health
education
but it was you know conveyed to us by
parents i don't want a person
of the opposite gender working or
working with my child and
and so
um
we had a school nurse that happened to
be she was wonderful
and we had a pe teacher that all the
years and there's several te teachers
laying around here
uh that were
was very good with and knew all the boys
there was a wonderful relationship so we
went that way especially with the kids
in grades
five and six
um
how who
how in your experience who has done this
who has done this instruction are
schools having to go find a
professional like yourself or do they
find a school nurse or do they how do
they convey this this need
to the kids you know a lot of parents i
got my instruction my father when we
were looking at the university of maine
to go to school there a little late
um yeah so
so i won't tell you what my father told
me well probably nothing if they're like
mine
so um but anyway uh rep how can you help
me out with uh who do we use for this
instruction is there a special training
or what i think there's some training
and there are materials that are now
widely available that are helpful and i
do think uh that that wiggle room that
was talked about previously
matters
to some extent too there are materials
out there but i don't think it's
complicated and i
i agree with you that the relationship
matters that the kids have to uh believe
that this person is giving you something
that's helpful and that's important and
they have to transmit it in a way that
is meaningful to you personally that
connects with you
personally i know you know look a lot of
us can remember the gym teacher teaching
us
sex education and it not being so great
you know
but i think that schools are much more
kipp to that i think schools have come a
long way since when we were kids and i i
think they can't find the right people
on the ground
to do this i don't think you have to
bring in outside people it's just not
that complicated
thank you very much
uh
yes represent cordelia thank you mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
is this intended
to be
part of
existing
curriculum are we talking new curriculum
it has to be developed
no i think it just fits right in i think
it slides right in with current health
education okay i was getting uh some
mixed messages about whether it was
part of existing courses or
something new to be added
yeah it it's simple it's not complicated
it's pretty small it's not costly
at all it's not really a cost
issue
and there are people in the community
like some of the people who spoke who
will speak today or have spoken today
who i'm sure will give their time to
schools to to help them with this
thank you very much thank you any
uh pamela
keeley is it
kylie well sort of there you were very
close
uh good afternoon mr chair and members
of the committee
my name is pamela keilig and i'm the
public policy specialist from the new
hampshire coalition against domestic and
sexual violence
as some of you may know the coalition is
the umbrella organization for our 12
community-based crisis centers who each
year provide free and confidential
services to nearly 15 000 survivors of
sexual and domestic violence in our
state
i just want to briefly speak in support
of hb 1533 and i really appreciate the
opportunity to testify today
this legislation is critical to
interrupting and ending the cycle of
violence in new hampshire
we know that violence prevention
education has an immediate effect on the
youth and families that participate in
these programs and their ability to get
the support that they need often
as i think you've heard earlier today
after attending these lessons children
will disclose abuse to a trusted adult
and later our crisis center advocates
and educators are able to assist the
student victims and their families who
engage with the child advocacy centers
and through the criminal justice process
if that's what they'd like to go
because of this education students have
come
to understand what healthy relationship
dynamics look like and learn how to
identify unhealthy relationships and
grooming behaviors
all important skills that will have long
lasting impacts on their development as
they grow into mature adults
what this legislation proposes will only
improve our response as a state to
ending sexual violence as we continue to
maximize our efforts to prevent abuse
before it occurs so this is a really
critical prevention
effort right here
and i know
it was also mentioned but we do have a
violence prevention educator from one of
our member programs who can definitely
speak more to the specifics of those
programs based on her
years and years of experience
implementing these really beneficial
programs
but thank you so much and i'd be happy
to answer questions thank you very much
are there any questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
next person is emily murphy
you emily your your
wrote down information
uh
and didn't check whether you support
oppose or what so
we oftentimes have people that have
technical support or information like
that to you know advise so
perhaps what you can do is
uh
if you have some further information to
provide us fine or if a committee member
has a question
we can ask okay we can go either way is
it okay for me to read my testimony or
should i yes you may yes you may okay
yeah
i took my glasses oh and by the way if
anybody has testimony that you're
reading that you did not bring uh
provide to the clerk here
it helps a lot if we can just put that
in
the record
and not have to
do it ourselves through our own
penmanship
go ahead sorry to bother emily oh no
thank you go ahead i am learning the
ropes
so good afternoon mr chair and members
of the committee my name is emily murphy
and i'm a violence prevention educator
for haven
which is one of new hampshire's
community-based crisis centers that
serves individuals and families in both
stratford and rockingham county
i'm here to provide educational
information
for hb
1533 which will add education on consent
and preventing sexual violence in our
state's health education curriculum
thank you for this opportunity to
testify about this valuable legislation
today
this bill is about health education and
the well-being of new hampshire children
preventing sexual violence is key to
healthy development
we see the importance of smoking
prevention education because of the
damaging health effects
it's important enough to be part of
health curriculums
the negative health impacts of child
sexual abuse and other forms of sexual
violence are staggering
they include depression
post-traumatic stress disorder
substance abuse and even suicide
brain scans have shown that children who
have been abused
can have similar changes to the brain as
soldiers in combat
the pain and suffering and difficulties
of having to live with sexual violence
not only hurts the individual but
families too
and this is not to mention the
incredible health care costs from that
trauma
not providing education to prevent
something so profoundly impactful
can be devastating to our communities
this is especially important in new
hampshire
where one in four women and one in 20
men have reported being sexually
assaulted
what is particularly horrifying
is of those
reported 41 of sexual assaults against
girls occur occurred before the age of
18.
and when you're talking about boys
of sexual assaults committed against
boys occurred before the age of 18.
it is our responsibility to protect
young people in our state
and providing adequate education on
consent and sexual violence prevention
is essential in order to ensure they
grow up healthy happy and safe
i have been doing sexual violence
prevention education in schools for over
17 years
it is not always the easiest job but is
incredibly rewarding
i can't count how many times a teen has
come up to thank us for doing this
education or disclosing that they were a
survivor and they were so grateful that
we were there
or the eighth grade girl who came up to
me at the end of the presentation asking
if it really really if it i'm sorry if
it really really wasn't too late to tell
if she could really tell
or the eighth grade boy who disclosed to
a guidance counselor after our workshops
that he'd be in sec he had been sexually
abused by his babysitter when he was
younger
this boy had been seeing a therapist for
years for unresolved anxiety yet the
past abuse never came up in all those
sessions
until he participated in that
school-based prevention education he
hadn't recognized what had happened to
him as abuse because the babysitter was
female
kids deserve this education it can be a
literal lifeline
telling someone you have been or are
being sexually abused or assaulted is
not easy
and then not talking about it only makes
it that much more difficult and the
silencing of victims and survivors can
be just as harmful as the abuse itself
and kids don't automatically know what's
okay
social media and the culture at large
can send very strange messages
about whether you need consent
and what a healthy relationship looks
like
they are getting education on these
things but in inappropriate and
sometimes dangerous ways
leaving this type of education to social
media influencers and the like is unfair
ensuring that there is developmentally
appropriate trauma aware education
around consent and sexual violence
prevention can neutralize some of the
toxic media that kids are inundated with
on basically a daily basis
but what about a parent's comfort in
this being taught
according to david finkelhor from the
crimes against children research center
at unh
multiple studies have found that
parent-child communication improves
after involvement in prevention
education
and with that in mind i want to end with
a letter haven where i work
received from a new hampshire parent
my daughter is in second grade and today
she came home with her pamphlet and
coloring book we went over it and i
asked her a lot of questions she was
clearly paying attention to you
my husband and i both knew when our kids
were born that we would fear the same
things that happened to us happening to
them
we were afraid of scaring them by even
talking about it would they think the
world is an awful place would talking
bring back those awful feelings that we
remember from our own vastly different
traumatic experiences
could the years of anxiety that we felt
as adolescents transfer to them but if
we never talked about it how could we
teach them to
so we have said many of the same things
to our children that you did
stressing stressing that their bodies
belong only to them
teaching about consent and that no
matter what
they can tell us anything
i am so happy that an organization like
yours exists
thank you for what you are doing
and that's the end of that that letter
so in in conclusion
hb 1533 will help ensure that education
on consent and sexual violence
prevention is taught in our schools
for all those kids and adults who have
already suffered and to help our current
and future youth live healthier and
freer lives
thank you very much and thank you for
um listening to me thank you very much
are there any questions
not yes represent lakers
thank you can you give me a guess or
give us a guess as to how long
the instruction
takes like how much out of a year's time
would be spent on this uh sure i mean it
can it can vary you know school to
school for for haven and the schools
that we go into
um for the
our kindergarten program is 45 minutes
and that's just once a year i mean
there's other things that can supplement
for us coming in it's just 45 minutes
and then
first through sixth grade it's an hour
long presentation
and then um seventh grade it's two
sessions and then two one-hour sessions
and then eighth grade it is um three
one-hour sessions
and that's over an entire year
thank you very much you're welcome
as a follow-up to that do you have a
sample curriculum that you use for that
yeah we use a curriculum that's based on
a lot of different information or a lot
of different resources so it's research
based
there are evidence-based curriculums out
there as well and we we use a research
it'd be nice to have some information
like that this bill the way it's written
goes in effect 60 days after after
that's not a lot of time for
school districts that gear up with a
curriculum
in fact and training and inclusive so uh
you know if you have something please
you know make it available
yeah yeah i can i can certainly um yeah
follow up and i know for us we we do the
actual presentations and we do them free
of charge to the schools
so that they don't necessarily have to
they can just have us come in you're
going to come up to colebrook
there should be an agent there are there
are agencies across the
across the state that do this type of
education thank you very much any
questions further follow-ups thank you
uh we have a card right here from
thank you good afternoon
uh my name is alberto soto i'm a
licensed doctoral level psychologist and
the uh
director of counseling
at middlebury college
um i'm here to talk in support of this
bill
throughout my career i've worked at
counseling centers at brigham young
university in utah brown university
and swarthmore college
undoubtedly
the biggest presenting concern that
shows up in a counseling center
is related to trauma
when i was at brown university i was a
transformative practices specialist
where i specialized working with
students who had caused harm
and so i work with students on both ends
of the trauma cycle
consent is both a
teachable skill
and it is context dependent
which means that there are number of
factors that impact the understanding of
consent
and so the ability to tune into that
is dependent on those social skills
and it's age-appropriate it's
developmental it builds on just like
learning algebra
it builds off of previously learned
material and previously learned skills
education is a great equalizer
and
the only way that we can help prevent
harm
is through education and through
preventative measures
preventative measures such as this by
teaching consent will go far will have a
far broader reach
than treatment
where after harm has been caused
students can be in the counseling center
for years and years trying to treat the
trauma
of what happened whether they caused the
trauma or they were the recipient of
trauma
and so i am incredibly supportive of
this bill and think that it will have
far-reaching effects not just for
students here in new hampshire
but students from new hampshire as they
go out to other colleges other
universities where they're interacting
with people from different cultures
people from different regions
so i am supportive of this bill and
think that it will have a broad reaching
effect in preventing trauma and harm
thank you very much are there questions
yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming to speak to us today
from your experience
with
individuals who have caused harm
what do you think the impact would be on
the rate
of
individuals who cause harm
had they been consent trained themselves
as as kids
yeah
yeah so so
clinically
um
the experience of seeing students who
have received uh consent training
it greatly reduces the risk of causing
harm empirically that's also supported
if they do cause harm it tends to be
less impactful
and perhaps the biggest thing is that it
normalizes the fact that consent is a
complicated construct
that can be learned
and is difficult for many people to tune
into
so when people do cause harm they're
much more likely to come and ask for
help because it reduces shame it reduces
stigma around something like consent
where we tend to think of relationships
as being fairly simple and sexual
interactions as being simple but they're
incredibly complicated
and so this goes a great way to reducing
stigma and shame if harm is caused and
it does a great deal of effort to reduce
thank you are there further questions
not seeing hands thank you very much
thank you
okay uh we do not have any other pink
cards for this bill so i will conclude
this hearing
and we're going to take about two
minutes and then come right back to open
up our last hearing
the last card
from mr soto i think he has his phone
number reversed there on there
if he's from vermont it's 802 it's 802.
i'm sure yep i know that would be true
and i'm not the one
i don't want to embarrass him so i'll
just let's just change it
good catch mr chair
well my vet's over there
my kids are over there there are doctors
over there
207 is maine 802 that's right exactly
we're coming down
that's my stuff
so i was late this morning to get my
comcast cable
back
i just asked
because he's a uh he's a friend and i
if i hadn't been here i could have
peppered him with a
i know
yeah i hated to miss that
because i
yeah i know that he was
hoping to just just done that jasper
earlier
well that sounds like it's a good thing
i think i i'm just
anticipating
the language is presented today
it's just why you read the three parts
of it that i have questions about
definition
but i mean as somebody who looks at that
line
under the law
i don't think there will be any conflict
today
well you know
i mean the wheels are turning and i know
when when i
was great
so
yes
one last bill here on the docket for
today it's house bill 1144 requiring
public schools to teach labor history
and represent gallagher you are here
ready to present
welcome
so
hi i'm eric representative eric
gallagher from uh
merrimack county district 15 that's ward
6 here in concord
i grew up
here
in concord went to
concord public schools
rudford elementary roadlett middle
school and concord high school
and
so one thing
one thing i heard a lot in the school
system
growing up was that
the
teachers are trying to
the workplace for getting a job for what
they're going to do when they grow up
and
looking back on it one thing that i've
realized
is
that
um
to the extent that they do that
what exactly
skills
what skills students need to use in the
workplace
a lot of its bias towards the employer's
point of view
and there's not really
as much education from
the workers point of view of what sort
of
skills they might need to
stand up to their boss
to
fight for higher wages and better
and
so
i think
i think a way
to help
students better learn
how to do that would be to look at
some historical examples of
how exactly
fought for improved
uh workplace conditions in the past
so
that's why
i decided to
introduce
this bill to add
labor history to
the
to the
public schools history curriculum
so
um
it's a pretty simple bill just a few
lines
so um
it took
um
it took two drafts
the one thing i changed was
to make sure to specify that this is as
part of the standard history curriculum
like
it's not
um
i'm not saying schools need to
create a separate class for it or
anything
just that
they should mention something
about labor and
their regular history classes
um
and
uh yeah i think that would
that would help
improve things for students so that way
they can know
what powers they have when they step
into the
workplace
from their own point of view rather than
just the
their employers so
that's the bill and i'll take any
questions
thank you very much representative are
there any questions for the
representative yes represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative i was just wondering what
you would uh see or what would you see
being meant by
other labor actions what would
be other later labor actions that should
be included in straight instruction
so there's another a number of things
that
that labor can do
um
in
in terms of negotiating with management
like
you know even just
the creation of the whole collective
bargaining process in the first place
like
i
heck i i don't even know how that came
to be in the first place that's
something i usually i'd like to learn um
you know how that got placed into law um
and i mentioned strikes um
there's other actions that labor can
take short of strikes
like work to rule for example where
you only do the stuff that's
specifically mentioned
in your contract
and
and not any of the extra stuff
there's
there's protests that aren't act are
technically strikes like for example
um
a few years back
uh when i was in college uh mark market
they're there for the keeping
arthur t demoulas as the chair of
market basket that wasn't technically a
strike or anything but the workers were
still protesting
and
um
fighting for their
uh
their preferences to be heard in the
corporate decision-making process so i
think that would count as something
that's
a labor action that isn't technically a
strike
thank you very much representative are
there further questions
not yes represent moffitt
famous chair do you envision this uh
word to move forward as being a
standalone course or embedded in an
existing course i'd see this as being
embedded in
the existing history curriculum
um just to
add some
add some extra
mentions of labor to
and new hampshire history curriculum
um
yeah i think i think that since it says
standard history curriculum that means
part of the
existing course rather than a standalone
thank you thank you very much further
questions
yes represent
ford
microphone
a question that comes to mind to me is a
former union president twice over
is that if you teach these subjects as
history per se
you have a way of fixing things in the
past
that may not be existing in the current
working conditions and i would
suggest that maybe you might want to
the idea of teaching as
something like working conditions or
some conditions of work rather than as a
history course
maybe a better place to look at would be
career planning or something like that
to include those kinds of things that
are contemporary
rather than historical because there's
been some brutal terrible
you know strikes as you know and things
like that and i'm not sure that those
are likely to happen again as they
worked out then
but they do point to the vehemence or
the or the feeling of
voice powerlessness that they felt and
they they grew out of that but right now
things are transforming dramatically
in the workplace
and so that what used to be management
is now part of
employment
and so the roles are changing and that's
what i think might be more useful to
contemporary students i ask that in
a sense of i think it's an important
subject just how do we go about
educating people
so um you mentioned
about how strikes used to be
violent in the past and
how we know that but the thing is i
don't think a lot of students these days
do actually know that
um
like
you know i i never i didn't really
learn about
violence being part of the labor labor
um
struggle
until i was in college
um
you know i i
i do think that
well yes
um
these things did happen in the past
the past is connected to the present and
a good history teacher ought to be able
to help students understand
how exactly the past
is
is connected to the president
so um yeah i do think
i think it's worth
keeping
um the historical perspective in this
bill but i would
i wouldn't be interested in
um
working on a bill to do some of those
other ideas you had
as well with you if you wanted to
thank you
further questions
not seen thank you very much thank you
with that i don't see i don't have any
other pink cards here so i'm going to
close this hearing on 11 44.
thank you and that concludes our docket
you